okay hello
are we live
hello
hello hello hello
chat chat chat chat chat chat chat hello
[Music]
are we live are we live
I don't know I can never tell until
people say
hi
you are maidenless we are live poggers
well you guys don't say that
right
YouTube chat doesn't say poggers
what do you say
I'm not live
freak
do you say poggers too
augers is cringe and Normie is that the
opposite like you're you're a normie if
you don't say poggers
you're collecting every spell I don't
know
we're gonna do every boss oh I need to
pull up our boss spreadsheet
thank you for reminding me
which is at the pinned is the PIN
comment if you would like to follow
along
but welcome everyone
[Music]
for our first stream
at 100
000 subscribers
augers
right is that poggers
woo
yeah I'm gonna try and not use any
physical attacks I'm going to only be a
wizard
yep every remembrance
every boss in the game we're gonna do a
hundred percent run again
let's go Nathan I hope you enjoy it man
it's also uh the game is 30 off isn't it
literally
from software games never go on sale by
the way so go ahead and go ahead and get
that
just so you guys know and you know if
you have a little uh thing for our
character here
his name is Perry hotter
I thought that was pretty creative and
funny
Harry
Potter
LOL
meteor staff and rock Slinger Opie
um well I don't know if I want to do a
ton of setup we're just going to play
the game man
I haven't done that in a while to be
honest
I Platinum this game about 150 hours
still don't think I've encountered every
boss this game is never ending dude you
got to get a spreadsheet you gotta get
you know all the stuff
how do you stay motivated to keep
playing Elden ring
um
because of my YouTube channel to be
honest
it's gonna be totally honest with you
okay first question before we start is
that too much chat on the screen
do we need less chat
it goes away every 20 seconds but you
guys talk a lot a good amount
I stab 72 people in the streets haha
Perry hotter all right
yeah it's 30 off chat seems fine I eat
all right make it the whole screen
nah
happy Hunter K thank you
I was
I can't believe that we got 100k
on Christmas that was kind of crazy
that made me happy let me rest
make it daytime
thank you thank you
it's very exciting
you guys know how long we were at like
90 000. that's the that's the other part
though
does anyone know how long we are at 90
000.
or it like within the 90 thousands let's
go get torrent
it's a long time
thank you Mike
didn't I make it daytime it feels like
night time
it was literally four or five months
that we were at 90
000. I think it was four four months we
were at 95 000.
so it took us four it took us
three months to get 95 000 and then
another four months to five months to
get five thousand bro
isn't that crazy
I actually got soft locked
do I need anything from our boy here do
you guys so I've never done uh a
sorcerer build in this game do I need to
like upgrade my staff and stuff like is
that a thing you do or do you just get
better spells
Bells
it was calculated
thank you North
I'm not using this is why hander again
you do upgrade staffs okay cool thank
you
and it literally makes it better
oh not bad
okay
a couple hits just like a sword
yeah I've never done a wizard build ever
ever
you instantly run to get the meteor
staff okay where is the meteor staff I
will go there right away
also are we good on sound and everything
everything cool everything fresh
it's our first stream so we gotta get it
figured out
it's in caled oh son of a [ __ ]
oh yeah don't I have to kill the uh
one of those can't remember the name
Chris Stallions in uh
no that's not it that's where I get a
smithing stone or whatever
a bell
it's inside the lake really
it's in a lake
see I've never went and got it
I don't have to kill anything yeah but
things are going to try and kill me
right
no enemies or bosses to kill Rock sling
is also there
are you guys strongly suggesting that I
go and do that
from Beyond the fog
I am Elena who is Grayson why do I keep
finding her
Grace is like that X who will not let
you go
I JM
It's s scaling that's pretty good
I offer you an accord personally Melina
is my waifu of Elden ring a lot of
people pick Ronnie but I pick Melina
have you heard of the finger maidens
they serve the two fingers
offering guidance
you guys like my character to the
tarnished made him yellow
but you
I am afraid
are made in this
I can play the role a long time ago easy
I would go way back in the videos into
strength I used to make builds here in
your search for the Eldon ring
Melania is a kinky Choice it really is
only take me with you Millicent enjoyers
to the foot of the earth tree it's old
Homer Simpson no this is Perry hotter
Harry Potter chat
summon Me by grace
to turn runes into strength
Alexander wow okay ah another matter I'm
gonna listen all the dialogue again too
use this ring
a hustle to Traverse great Barry rotter
okay you can call him old Homer spectral
steed
torrent
torrent you can Canon marry Ronnie
yes treat him with respect but think
about Melina she lit herself on fire for
you
do you think Ronnie would do the same
hell no
that's why melon is the waifu
hey thanks mug I appreciate it man okay
so you guys really are saying that I
should go to Caleb huh like right now
because we can gas it right over there
not hard
Larry Flopper
so I go there and just not kill anything
and grab it and leave
all right we can do that
you will have to remind me where it is
exactly but we will go in that direction
okay
I'm gonna grab some stuff on the way
[Music]
blue
she's the Cavalry night dude in caled I
do know how to do that we can try it if
you want
what does Melina say here oh I remember
she talks about the grace
tiny Golden Aura is the grace of the
earth tree hell yeah it is once Shone in
the eyes of your tarnished brethren
now
it is all that guides you
also I hear
you can see Melinda couldn't ruin my
life the Rays of Grace
that guide you through your burden
upon the cliff in Castle storm Vale
is a Shard Bearer a demigod who
inherited a fragment of the shattered
Elden ring if the Rays of Gray's signals
thanks easy so then the Eldon ring yeah
what up Brandon as an ally by Pat
no this is a this normal game face the
challenge not new game by the ring
[Music]
they have more grace
I think they're just overloaded on runes
for their size does that make sense
[Music]
everyone's I feel like no one picks
rodurika as their waifu
they crossed the sea for me they fought
for me
only to have their arms taken should
have gone prisoner I'm a wizard though
taken
taken and stuck to the spider yeah what
about Ryan if you're grafted by the
spider she's got that gamer posture
become a chrysalid
she's basic about it
I don't know man
what if you were like submissive or
never mind now I'll stop
and heading to stormvale Castle enticed
by the one in
start with the staff
oh I have a staff
with the spider well that makes us two
peas in a pot but I don't know honestly
it doesn't matter it it's scary you know
having your arms cut off or legs or your
head
I want to be like everyone else but
she's just too scared I take this as the
all of the tarnish that came with her
literally came here to die or to have
their body parts cut apart is that how
you guys take it as well
tanet is low-key fine but then she
starts eating Reichard and it gets kind
of weird
is that how you guys take that dialogue
right there like
she came here to literally get all of
her body parts cut up and given to the
spider
dog no one's picking dung eater
yeah they're expected to be grafted
okay oh wait
I know can you take this little one
along with you
the spider is talking about the grafted
Scions or probably godric the grafted
someone braver than myself
and the spirits look rather fondly upon
you they were defeated by the grafted
Scion and taken to godric then why is
she talking like that like there it's
kind of scary
but I'm too scared to do it you know it
it does not sound like they were
defeated by anything it's that they came
here to to give themselves away
basically that is definitely how I take
it when I listen to this
it was a pleasure to see you oh
she never saw guidance she was likely
sent away the form of Exile tell them I
love them I mean what she's saying is
that she never even tried she's too
scared
see the hang of this whole pain thing
you know like why would she say that if
they were like defeated by anything
that's silly
that's silly Billy
whoops
break
I don't have a gun
okay let me grab this stuff
real quick it'll help later it'll help
later
[Music]
it she definitely talks like it's
expected of her at least where she comes
from
foreign
thanks bloodborne
come come come
we're going directly to the swamp and
Caleb right
okay
really
laughs
I sent for women that would straight up
kill me okay good
good good good
oh I bet you can kill Reichard with just
rock sling
is Rock sling still like really really
good
meteorite ruins
let's talk to Alexander
[Music]
hello can you hear me since we're here
oh my stars I'm so happy to see you I am
Alexander tauren didn't really die Fist
and I just got I got knocked off it's
two different animations either torrent
dies or you get like uh
knocked off Torrent from like uh boys my
thanks a thousand thanks just give me a
good smack from the world do I have to
smack him with my with my Wizard and
I'll pop clean out I'm sure like can I
hit him with sorcery no there's no need
to fret I'm very well trained you you
are David you're all I say very well
trained sir okay well let me try this
yeah yeah
wow actually pretty strong
I've had some swords take like four or
five hits to get him out
well played good sir well played oh that
Mighty Wallop of yours almost no I'm not
using a sword for this run at any point
hahaha ah
well
I'm out now and that's what counts I am
strictly Harry hotter the wizard and as
a token of my appreciation
is very differences
from what I've usually done
thank you
pleasure is mine
I am the warrior job Opie Savage
Reichard Boss Arena the base of strength
and wind attacks
education
and Beyond these lands lie the Scarlet
rot blighted Khalid Ronaldo will
actually be hard with this build for
sure
in which a festival of combat is
behind heard Whispers of such
festivities before
doesn't the notion set your breasts are
flutter
the bigger the bug the better the bubble
to slay the gods to turn them to Rubble
watch where you step or you may tumble
in the prepare to face your final tumble
I think you said tumble too many times
there
I like it though
if you use Rock sling that does physical
damage well you know what I mean
I can only use spells
I don't want to use a sword is what I
mean
intended to be Rumble at the end got it
wait Melina talks here
huh
give me new dialogue me
um
for my purpose
given to me by my mother inside the
earth tree
long ago just say queen America could I
yet live
burned and bodyless
there is something magic sword things
must apologize
I've acted the finger Maiden
yet can offer no guidance
I am no mater Ronaldo won't be that hard
well yeah with physical damage right
that's what you meant
we're gonna get all the sorceries we are
gonna be
Harry hotter just an absolute stud
muffin
okay I'm not killing this guy
honestly their lore is kind of sad
and I don't want to touch them
here we go
Harry plotter
Serpentine blade is that the poison
blade
you like poison
ah a tarnished are you I'm known as d
I hunt down those who live in death
we'll get all the magic the death route
heed my warning The Village here has
been touched by Death
and worse yet
um if you value your life
Harry Potter
Harry Potter
dead
okay wait wait
shoot I can't all right whatever
D's a nerd anyway
honestly one of my least favorite
characters in the game to be totally
honest
now we're going to get the staff
I have ADHD chat and I get distracted
please keep me on track
foreign
yeah I just don't think he's that
interesting
even though he is he he is interesting I
just you know compared to everybody else
I don't really like him that much
yeah we're doing all quest lines he's
fine
his quest line is
really straightforward
very straightforward
hey do we just go right past Anastasia
here yes
we do
uh oh I see
better got that data plan
I had a great Christmas
Joe how about you guys if you celebrate
whoa huh
forgive me what I've been testing you to
determine if the Elden ring would truly
have you I have not defeated an enemy at
all I think I've defeated one and
arduous path yes it's just on distance
my worries were unfounded torrent had
your measure from the very start
one other thing can do to offer you
guidance interesting I can take you to
the round table Hall Gathering Place of
tarnished champions
guided I think if you're in Lim grave
you have to be Margaret right very well
let my hand rest upon you
for but a moment
good job you moved very far on torrent
you must be very good
I had someone in the comments tell me
that they played 80 hours without going
to the round table because they never
left limgrave and never beat Market
isn't that crazy
some people are weird dog okay these
here
federica's not here yet
um yeah okay well we have the option to
be here that's chill
no they're not bad they just you know
some people like exploring okay chat
where am I going am I going over there
to the uh
the
Swampy
is that where we're going
this is scary
I don't know about this
played 130 and just beat Ronaldo the
some people just play the game different
best trap
chest trap
is that in this area
ignore the dinosaur dogs
it's hitting Graces as I see them
the shoe and go in the direction of
where it lands honestly that's how
this game should be played
what up coach
I went the wrong way I'm going around
bruh
ow
that hurt
foreign
thank you femi
it is very cool
I got a partner manager now chat Isn't
that cool
that's some guy from YouTube
congratulate me
Rock sling the whole game confirmed
oh Unga Bunga strength build
no I'm letting chat tell me where to go
they said I need the meteoric slave or
staff
yes right this way I would imagine means
like giant sword that's how I always
play
this is like my first time doing
anything that isn't just like a giant
sword to be honest or like at night
oh
um I'm not from YouTube and it doesn't
matter to me but if I get more videos
after a decent
after a DLC I'll be happy not from
YouTube welcome
you're on YouTube forehead
all right where am I going
I don't remember where the staff is
oh the giant Crusher
that's unga bunka okay
into the swamp Okay where before I go
there
I think everything in this area will one
shot me
left
is it over here
Street of sages
all right how do I get it is it down
here
hey
we got rock sling we need the staff
poggers
step one complete
oh is that good
no well maybe
lands between map was written in ancient
Chinese
what does that mean
it's on a window
like in this area same area
well back in the corner
I'm assuming not down there though right
it's good for resistances
can't be this
there it is
found it
said can't be this
there it is all right so
do I get the flipping heck out of here
okay no sword none of that
I can't even use it yet I need 18 inch
and I have 16.
okay that's easy
all right who do we go beat first
get the [ __ ] out yeah
that's uh that's what I thought let's
try and beat this guy
the uh
the [ __ ] boy
I'm in trouble may I have a word
she talks to you like you're in trouble
man I'm telling you oh yeah let's do the
knights Cavalry cheese I will read
pleasure to meet the tarnished this is
so cinematic
I'd heard Hotel of a tarnished hurting
about Atop A spectral steed and upon
looking into the matter
talk about eyes I love this game this
game is so good
to call forth this actual Steve named
torrent it's like ridiculous effort I
can't get over it never will I was
entrusted this for thee
we're doing all the quest lines
I'm not saying no there's a bow of
calling forth spirits
summon them with it
from Ash and return dude does anyone
even talk about God of War anymore
anything command but briefly I feel like
people did for a week
thanks Peter I think do it as thou
wishest
thanks Ronnie I love you mine intrusion
tarnished I doubt we shall again meet
but all the same
learn while the lands between it's
basically open world Dark Souls 3. yeah
that's great listens to the two fingers
was it Melina does Ronnie know her
who do you guys think was the previous
owner of torrent
or Torrance former master who do you
think that is
only those making fun of Quantum TV and
sorts
Peru
only takes a week to beat Ragnarok yeah
I agree swirl
[Music]
Ronnie or her mother I mean it's
definitely not Ronnie because she just
said it's her by her the former master I
guess it could be
why would she say it like that though
by Torrance former master
me and
wouldn't it be Melina because she gives
us the whistle that summons him and she
was writing him before
which would be the glomide queen that
makes sense
so probably Melina or you know the
glomide queen version of her
does that make sense all right let's
beat this guy in the rain let's go baby
it's gonna be so easy I'm not even
worried
I'm a pro gamer at this point
I need more blue pots
[ __ ]
what the
oh I forgot he could do that
that scared me
how good is this
this guy can't even hit me he's trash
how far does this go
well
I need more blue pots
you know what I'm gonna do
I didn't lose this fight chat
I took a tactical retreat
y'all saw it
okay we gotta allocate this [ __ ] let's
just do a three bang or three Banger for
now
more pots okay we're right back at it
tactical Retreat that's just [ __ ]
smarts right
oh that's a waste
almost died to a pole
why is it like always night time right
now
it's kind of nice
[ __ ]
oh
that's unfair I thought it wouldn't work
again
okay let it go man
no
okay I was just far enough away
oh
remember when people struggled with this
guy
to a point of where they didn't like
finish the game because of him didn't
even play it
not crazy
foreign
doubling up huh okay
am I allowed to use his shield
if I get it somewhere down the line
is that a spell
it probably requires Faith though
if I had to guess
one way through him bro
[ __ ] you
[Music]
foreign
bro this is so nice
bathe caster
we'll see how it goes we'll see we'll
see
some of these just legit Miss
nice
[ __ ] oh I'm dead it's over
I'm alive
no not like this
I forgot he swings three times there
whoa that's a good follow
come on baby
foreign
[Music]
almost got him
am I allowed to use my shield
or my sword if I run out of Mana
don't have to answer that question
because it's over
and he's dead
you know what I would have done this
all right let's talk to our boy up here
[Music]
okay so I'm allowed to Parry is what
you're saying
we're doing pure ant build okay
all right we got 18.
I'm gonna level our Vigor because it's
really low
all right we should be able to use this
step why do you guys
oh this one's just literally better and
it's already s scaling for INT
holy titties bro okay that's big
oh my God he's playing the video game
known as Elden ring Game of the Year
2022 Perfect 10 score by many reviews
crew
that crazy
all right so we're like literally the
best now right like it's just we're a
god at this point
what's not upgradable the meteoric staff
isn't upgradable
oh wow why is that
right Bill Clinton want Bill Clinton won
game of the year guys
Eldon ring lost to Bill Clinton
God what a great stream that was
what an amazing day
maybe it doesn't want to be upgradable
mind your business okay sorry
okay so it levels within so I'm just
gonna level in
now question
let me go to my list going to my list
who did we just beat
we beat it's just called the tree
Sentinel right yep pecked off
dead
um
on this list chat
is Rick
do we go kill Rick now
do we really go down there and do that
we do we really do this
let's go kill Rick
you want to save Rick to be the last
boss we do in the entire game
okay that's actually funny let's go
cheese the caled calorie dude
the final boss already
okay we'll beat Rick literally last
where is this guy he's up there right
I want to go back here
who's Rick that's a shame
that's a shame bro
he's literally
a he's the god of Gods
how long do you plan to stream today
um until I don't want to anymore
is that a good answer
yeah Rick Ashley
I am like scared to be here this is like
not
suggested
tough but fair
this stream could go another 10 minutes
chat or it could go another six hours
have you tried mods oh yeah I have
modded the living [ __ ] out of this game
to make videos but I don't have any mods
on right now besides making the game
look better that is it
foreign
do you guys even like long streams
I get so like if I go over four hours
people always come in here like whoa
holy [ __ ] you're still live
what
all right check it out you want to see
how the game really looks
wait
that's how it really looks
this makes it look a little bit cleaner
normal
clean
probably when it's not raining and dark
you'll see a major difference
no difference shut your mouth Mike
silly goose
you'll only watch for at least two hours
bro
[Music]
exactly Gustav
exactly
I'm gonna get yelled at
it's just called Reese re-shade I
believe
this makes the lighting and the shading
a little bit better
uh I'm not going the right way
can you try out evil West
listen here's what I've learned by
streaming other games
you guys don't want to see anything but
Elden ring baby
and I'm cool with that
you guys know I got two copyright
strikes for the when we played high on
life
because I watched that dumb movie on the
TV in the game
is that stupid
okay that one looked alive for a second
I was like what
uh I think we go down here don't we yeah
or I got two copyright claims not
strikes
I went to the bathroom or to take the
dogs out real quick
and left my character looking at the TV
in the game and those are copyrighted
movies
I'm like what
it was fun though
are you interested in Dragon lore
I'm really not is that bad
I I find dragons to be at this point in
gaming like kind of cliche
where it's like yeah they're cool but
they're like really overdone
you know what I mean
oh wait I can cheat my way in here right
wait watch this watch this
wait
oh [ __ ] I'm dead it's over
I'm alive
I went the wrong way
and we're in
let's go
[ __ ] you
oh okay
I probably should have got the thing
outside yeah it's how you're supposed to
get in here Finn I'm you know I wanted
to look cool and now you ruined it
because you know somebody out there was
like what
we got another memory Stone let's get it
I could kill the little wiener Hut Jr in
here but nah we're good
it made him look so old
is it weird that torrent can't activate
the pressure plate
yeah it's because he's a ghost
that's actually not true but we can say
it is
all right I don't remember how to
exactly do this so we're probably gonna
die like two or three times but here we
go
here we go here we go
here we go hey you [ __ ]
[Music]
okay
um I forgot I had Rock sling equipped
and thought that would be a lot faster
[Laughter]
is called a spectral Steed true
hey at least it's light out now why am I
all the way over here bro
did I not hit the grace
did I just not do it
I didn't
I thought I did no
no
oh I'm stupid aren't I
I just left huh
I'm a little stupid
look at me trying to be the lore guy in
Elden ring and I'm this dumb
come on Jake
if you want to be like vati you got you
just gotta be better than this
has got to be better
good people become members
so you guys see on the left side of the
screen under the chat
you see it says like locomotive and then
you'll see a little red heart I did the
same thing as before
the heart
I can't really see it it says 39 out of
100.
if we get to a hundred members I will do
something that you guys want me to do
now we can come up with that as a team
as a community but we got to get to the
hundred Members Mark to do
now I did this on Twitch all the way up
to 2500 subscribers by the way
where I did some really weird [ __ ]
extremely odd stuff
I dressed up as Princess Peach one time
that's true David
okay wrong Bridge
it does show on screen when people
become members yes
unless it breaks then it's not my fault
redone cosplay
we can do something like that
we can dye my hair blue and we can paint
my face blue to look like Ronnie or
something
but we got to get to 100 members
right now we're at 39.
we can do a feet stream that is
something we can do
yeah my game looks nice Rod thank you
you want a maid cosplay we could do that
as well
so there you go now we got a new member
thank you Gustav it should come up on
screen or I'm going to scream
we're done cosplay we can do that too
there it is baby
thank you Gustav
[Music]
by the way chat it's three dollars I
think
there we go sometimes you just gotta
mention memberships exist
okay here we go
here we go baby we just gotta get him to
jump
[ __ ]
he didn't jump
all right Gustav twisted and Steven
thank you guys for becoming tarnished
welcome to the community I appreciate it
now we're at 42 out of 100.
and we can come up as a community in the
Discord or hear what we want to do for
that milestone
and then I'll make a new one right like
we'll do 150 and then I'll do something
else does that make sense
I did this on Twitch for years and it
was really fun
but YouTube's like just kind of better
you know
YouTube is literally just a better
experience and yes you can gift members
if you're on not on mobile I think
yours is with a pH we got you bro
we got you look at Angel's been a member
for a long time and he's got a blue
crown
or a blue logo
sorry I'm kind of distracted right now
sounds like a scam
I mean why
you give me money and I do something
silly for you
you know I mean
there's a link in the description Toby
it'll say join the agency with a link
right next to it
you're saying the other side is better
I've only seen this side
I've done it before it's not easy
we just gotta get him to jump
jump you [ __ ]
okay what am I doing wrong
demon dragon takumi thank you bro
appreciate it man thank you thank you
angel
become a member we have fight clubs and
fun goals we do have fight clubs that I
want to do more often
I don't think I can quit out because I'm
literally dead like I'm dead dead
but demon thank you and Angel appreciate
the Super Chat as well man thanks
oh you're saying I should quit out well
then he won't notice I'm there
Don't Call Him a [ __ ] that's rude he
just didn't want to jump right right
sorry
by the way the people who are in The
Fight Club you guys can do the fight
club whenever you want I don't have to
be live you know what I mean
but I do want to start doing that more
regularly
the holidays came up bro and [ __ ] got
busy quick
you
okay I've seen it done here so I'm gonna
do it here
I you know
you know
you know how it is
how does that work we have a separate
Discord that you can join for the fight
club and then you just talk to them and
you can go to the coliseums together
and fight against each other for funsies
I think I'm bad at this chat how many
runes does this give me is this even
worth it
could have become a member because I'm
broke as [ __ ] and my father will kill me
if I ask for money
or maybe somebody will gift you a
membership
that'll be really cool
50k I bet
that's a lot
hound step now I'm not going to use that
I'm not a [ __ ]
all right let me try this side
I'm
scared
startled and frightened okay I'm going
over here
hold everybody hold
okay
I'm literally gonna Dodge you until you
jump
I [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
you join the patreon I haven't updated
the patreon in months
because nobody really liked it
you silly goober
God damn it
just fight him normally I don't think
that's gonna go super well
there's a link in the description flupa
flappa
are we gonna do this
that seems like really weird I see why
would I ever do that
you know what I've been thinking of
doing for members as well
Early Access to new videos dude
saying this is like if man if I get
touched I'm dead
what else do you do okay I see we can't
really make jokes like that I'm just
saying
I got wrecked okay we're gonna do this a
few more times
we can do it right
do you believe in me
probably not but let's see
this will literally be the second boss
we've bought
okay come on baby
first time playing shut your [ __ ] mouth
[ __ ] huh
come on get off the horse get off the
horse
hey where are you what the hell are you
doing over there come on
no shot
hey
oh God
I'm trying to look man just jump
jump
what
his horse looks so stupid
Toby thank you for the membership man
welcome to the tarnish good to have you
brother thank you thank you
it's glitching man
if I jump do I slide off
hit
yes
that's what I thought
oh God here we go
please please
grips let's go baby
let's go drips with the five gifted
members that's that you're literally the
first person to ever gift members on
this channel
okay here we go they all knowing you're
all knowing
[ __ ] I was distracted man
you are the first
I think my thing is broken but I
appreciate it drips thank you very much
man who got one print Stan Brandon retro
and fried huge they all know it I need
to be on the other side near the tree
okay I'll try that
it's kind of broken
oh no
all right drips thank you very much man
that's huge of you
absolutely massive
I think fried re-sub too let's go
you guys going nuts
no everyone who got a sub is also
getting a resub
foreign
what
all right whatever you guys get a lot of
alerts enjoy
okay tree branch near the Tree near the
tree this this Branch probably this
branch is what you're talking about
[ __ ]
[Music]
you like that see that Dodge [ __ ]
torrent man
he didn't jump when I pressed jump
just didn't do it guys I'm really bad at
this
what up Trey
I think we gotta do it though
like this will just make us instantly
cool
the other one
all right
here we go
yeah Trey's got the Purple Crown because
he's cool
great people are actually becoming
members like right now
isn't that crazy
you come
oh we did it let's go baby
let's go
I didn't even see him jump
hey hey we'll take it he's dead I didn't
even see it Gustav with a 6.75 Super
Chat thank you man more alerts
more alerts more alerts yay you guys
give me money and I do weird stuff or
hard stuff think about this like we
could do cosplays
like I could dress up as Ronnie and get
the webcam out like that'd be kind of
crazy
I can get some like fake arms or
something
um
or I can do like challenge runs like
you know
Rune level one challenge stream or
something like that if we get to like
500 you know
now this whole chat is members and I
like it
one more sub and we're at 50. or one
more member
snap
okay what am I putting my levels in is
it literally just intelligence or should
I level mind as well
please don't do cosplays and stuff I'm
begging you think of hard challenges dog
I swear to God I will dress up as as
radagon
I'll do it I'll be here shirtless
I'll paint myself with like a scar on my
face or something it'll be cool
or we can do challenge runs we we can
figure it out but we got to get there
first
mind and int
what is intelligence without mind
your mom okay
sorry
I know let's go Alexandra
whoa
let's go baby
thank you is this good can I do this
right here
welcome to the tarnished Alexandra good
to have you we are at 50 out of 100
we're halfway there baby
halfway there
that's fitty we're at like 30 earlier
blood cosplay I'll dress up as a furry
I'll get a furry cosplay and we'll play
it we'll do a speed run of the game how
about that
is a furry that's good all right let's
go fight uh oh let me let me get our
that's our second boss we've beaten by
the way
to go to Kalin
here
[Music]
um
Caleb
no let me let me click Caleb please
oh I see deselect all Khalid
Knights Calvary south of late aonia swap
only appears at night is that a
different one
Knight's Cavalry location on the on the
bridge and you get Bloodhound step it's
that one cool
heal
I'm such a good streamer
by the way
pinned at the top you can follow along
on there if you want to
with the boss list
become a v tuber we could do that for a
stream you know what I mean
any Co-op any Co-op
all right where do we go now what do I
do
I guess I can do anything do we just go
beat Margaret you think I can
let's see if we can beat Market
all right
cosplay see we can come up with all
these ideas but we gotta get there first
okay how about that chat
hot tub stream that is way down the line
that we do that by the way
like a hot tub stream would have to be
like a thousand members or something
you haven't met Lloyd
should we meet Bud uh we can come back
and meet blood after this
wide's a homie
until he's not
I'm scared to see what happens if I stay
around hey it's going to be interesting
whether you like it or not you know I
mean
cosplay is torrent
I'll get joy a couple of horns and she
can be torrent how about that that'd be
funny
I think we can make her a couple of
horns
okay I'm making it not nighttime it's
just constantly night right now
you know what I mean like I feel like
it's been night the entire time we've
been playing
five gifted memberships let's go
everyone claps and chat
that's 55.
55 baby we're getting there
whoa
thank you thank you appreciate it very
much
knowing
all right I'm gonna go beat up this old
man
make sure to thank
twisted if you got a gifted membership
please
almost doubled your member count in an
hour
you just gotta talk about it
[Music]
like I'm being straight up honest with
y'all the flame of ambition you give me
money and I do weird stuff
that's how this deal works
foreign
I'm confused now
I need to fix my alerts
snowing all right let's go market
236 that's pretty good right
wow
will he stagger
by that
I'm an idiot
jump [ __ ] yeah yeah
oh we gotta upgrade our flask bro oh my
God
foreign
yeah we gotta get physic too
whoa
you can't reach me right
I answered my own questions
astonished
God dang it
I'm in early transition
you're gonna do that yep
staggered by now
just
I'm dead
Twisted thank you again that's really
nice I know we're like just talking
about memberships but I really do
appreciate it I there's definitely not a
huge culture of becoming members on
YouTube
um like there is on Twitch we're just
[ __ ] changing that
okay I can I can beat him I just did
really bad
that was my fault
I gotta figure out how to be a wizard
you know
good stuff I see
uh-huh yep oh right right right whoops
look at that damage though 426.
don't jump
Warrior blood must truly run and die
veins
how many rooms do I have
I just want the rooms I got him I'm dead
these no English Ambitions to rest dang
it
huh
Bart
I can use emotes now you can we have
those although I don't think there are
major reason people would become members
though
okay 900 runes not that big of a dealio
I won't stress I won't stress
I could do the pebble but Rock sling is
poggers
so different from how I usually play
usually up in his face
wow
he's got some reach on that attack man
his daggers are annoying
oh my God oh my God that was awesome
holy [ __ ]
get annihilated
two of those missed
stop spamming stop stop
come on baby
easy peasy chat easy peasy
foreign
Potters
is Victorious
Coco became a great Rune thank you very
much I appreciate that thank you thank
you thank you
welcome
by the way if you're a new member make
sure to go to the community Tab and
you'll get access to the members only
Discord
that's where the fight Club is by the
way
thanks Coco
good to have you
what are we at now
56.
it's big
all right
hmm
should I level vigor
I think so I feel like that's going to
be more important right now
we could go south
and get all the flash upgrades
I think that's what we should do
okay deselect all we're gonna be in Lim
grave and we just beat Margate I gotta I
gotta make sure I'm checking the stuff
off chat
I do have to make sure I'm doing that
godric they're grafted okay where's
Market okay there he is Boom dead
dead
[Music]
as heck
int
well I level vigor
we'll be doing a lot of it
a lot
Castle Moore and Peninsula time let's do
it
let's go baby
I'm on PS4 I'm so sorry I am so sorry
I'm so sorry
bigger is for plessies get good
well there are other people who are on
PlayStation that you can play with by
the way I really wish the game was
counter or cross-platform that would be
awesome
no Maps
I feel like I'm at a point where I don't
need a map
definitely I know exactly I know where I
am all the time
I know this game like the back of my
hand I was gonna say something else but
never mind
Raj your request line we can we can
let's go talk to
Yuri
now let's talk to Patches then we'll
talk to
Irena
oh wait
Dragon time
oh my God
Dad I think you were right about rock
sling
oh yeah let's talk the Box
oh they fall
whoa why
three
started on a weird side
where are you going
foreign
I literally didn't know you could do
that
Arrow reached Talisman gotcha
feel like this is pretty good
go to the community tab on the channel
Stephen
I don't even have to aim Chet is this
cheating
man
oh one got him sick
oh
[Music]
do you guys believe there are people out
there who think this game is hard
they couldn't they're just trash they're
literally just trash
I'm just kidding
by the way saying stuff like that
actually triggers people
oh wait that takes me somewhere else I
do not want to be here
that takes me to Caleb
100 cheating
just get rock sling
that's the easy mode just kidding
you're a what up bro is it Euro
it's Europe
I'm not such
there's something you might like to know
you're a robot
it's used in drug and communion if you
should find yourself overcome by hunger
for the heart
yeah we have Bots
and seek the decrepit Church
on the little Island
yeah it's Yuri you must not forget
though those who partake in Dragon
communion
or one day shed their Humanity their
hunger for Dragon they're yearning
only worsens until the floodgates burst
after harm unleashing eternal torment
yes of a mighty dragon
magnificent there's a lot of stuff to
remember in this game
it's no surprise that drug and communion
um should we go do
uh uh the area over here then
patches
dude Death Note is a great anime by the
way
I think you guys have turned me into a
weeb
there's so many people suggesting
berserk
and berserk is really good
I did not think berserk would be as good
as it is and it's like kind of insane
we are not going to the manor no shot
bucko
we can go to Kenneth as well we should
just do this whole area we'll do Yura
we'll do Europe patches
penetite and then uh blyde on the way
over here
I've never watched bleach
never watched it
yeah berserk is like actually disturbing
I I can see that
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] is this chat oh no wait I
don't I don't have stuff
you're a help
for you
spot
s blood
oh wait I'm out of stuff we gotta let we
gotta let him take care of this
it does 108 damage
no it does eight damage
come on baby
wow
get him
oh we almost got him man
I think I just got I just got
annihilated huh
yep I'm only using the staff chat
at least I was fair there
nope no sword
I am a wizard I don't know what a sword
is
Harry hotter has no use for swords
you get to live
dual wield Bonk staff
oh we could go to selling too there are
a lot of quest lines here
in this area huh
and I died way the heck over here
fam time uh oh I'm dead
if it is hilarious
bloody finger bruh
I'm a wizard
ah
got him
okay
uh yep
we'll hit hatches
real quick
this whole area is huge well we talked
to Roger in the castle right Stormville
[Music]
it's Leviosa not Leviosa
[Music]
or which is it it's Leviosa not Leviosa
foreign
which ending are we going for
I mean I feel like the Ronnie ending
makes the most sense right
with this character
we'll see what we get to
am I gonna insta kill him
nope
a shield really
dude
wait wait please
I Surrender for Pete's sake I concede no
one likes a bull-headed brute you know I
yield yield you can't harm a yielding
man
grovel for Mercy finally come round have
you I knew you would you're a man of
Reason through Pete's sake oh I forgot
that Trump
um good shrimp
well what do you know you're tarnished
like me now how did I get that role I
took you for a demi-human or some such
we could go that route Mira I assure you
well water under the bridge
now we're squared up how about we play
nice from now on
okay the true man of reason
Just What I Like About You
I'm patches patches the untethered
tarnished like you only free-spirited
nomadic you might say only for now those
retired soldiers turned Bandits Waypoint
ruins
in exchange for my I'm forgetting where
that is showing them the ropes
maybe set up a legitimate the side at
the end Franklin so don't be a stranger
I'll be ready to wheel and deal come
next time
[Laughter]
Royal House scroll what does that do
what is that
don't forget to pop back for another
visit friend are we ready to wheel and
deal come next time
okay
we got him going
slicer spell huh is it good
like what are the best spells in the
game chat I have no idea
I mean should we just go to selling then
actually
yeah we should
is that really still the best one
okay
night Comet star ruin
gotcha
it hasn't gotten a Nerf
gotcha
we'll see how our build turns out
we'll try and mix and match you know
where is she up here
is she over here
uh my brain is so bad
oh I should grab these actually
it's like what is that it's a lid
it's more south yeah you're right
I got confused by these guys right here
but it's up here
hi member
dude she's not up here
we were wrong
what do Starlight shards do by the way
I've never found a use
hey there's your scroll
she's over there chat
refills FP over time
their currency for
an NPC
it's like Bitcoin for Mages
got it got it yeah she's right here
I'm I see it now
howdy Nick
God she got you
uh oh my God I'm burping a lot right now
I'm so sorry
all right uh how hard is egg head gonna
be
or pumpkin head
Chad I can't I can't even hit him
never mind
can I aim at the body
I gotta be up in them guts
nice
nice let's go easy
I'm clearly just a god-gifted gamer you
know
hmm I'll just go in you guys got mad
when I leveled Vigor so
int yet again
didn't expect a weak ass foe tarnished
are we
no wonder you should turn up here
stellen is like in my top three waifus
quite plainly why are you here
she's pretty cool
a Yen for Glenstone sorceries
well
your aptitude disappear
possible
but one must choose one's Masters wisely
I was exiled from The Academy of Raya
lucaria as a reviled apostate witch I
don't even know what that is at this
point in my playthrough
I don't know if that's good or bad sure
well you are a piece of work
very well
okay
I'm pretty crazy though never
anticipate grievances Young Apprentice
Ronnie Millicent fear mine's Melina
Melina Thea sellen for me
give scroll give Royal House scroll
wait was I supposed to give that to her
to my Academy days
very well
this is sorcery with which I'm not
entirely unfamiliar I'll be sure to
incorporate it into one of your lessons
was that bad never lose that inquisitive
Spirit my Apprentice
okay so we already have the pebble
glintstone Stars okay we already have
the ark
Crystal barrage Scholars armament
Tyrion slicer isn't this the one you
guys told me to get
yeah what should I get here
reforms swept sweeping slash with a
magical sword
y'all saying slicer
placer's op all right flies are required
should I get these just to have
like over my head whenever I just call
it it's like nice like extra damage
Maybe
are these like trash
you're all saying Glenstone stars as
well no okay
pleasure is great FP used for damage
wait what are we saying yes to now
there's great posture damage
you should put it on your Ash of War
okay
this
press one if I should get phalanx
what up Stan how are you sir
[Music]
yeah I guess I'll get them all
eventually right I just don't have the
runes to do so
all right we'll get these
can I make that my ash of War
Young Apprentice you are a tadpole when
it comes to Magic
I think that's all she says yeah okay
why
okay
I'm doing good Stan
glad you're doing well
all right so
I'm gonna get rid of the pebble I'm
gonna put carrion slicer on you guys
said I can make
Bay lanx and Ash of War
on my staff
[Music]
a tadpole
Roger has Asher War so we should just
wait for him
I'm gonna put that there for now
okay
make slicer first spell
chat
you're cute
does that matter
like where they're at
that's fine
well we'll have to go to we could go to
Roger now let's go so we came here 30
minutes ago to upgrade our flask let's
go do that first
first things first
we were gonna go do all the other quest
lines but we'll have to do that later
wrong way
finally
hey man ADHD
with a chat room while playing a game is
hard
plus I'm dyslexic and can't read it's
incredible that I can even do this
kind of incredible
I'm kind of the best
do I have like better clothes
nah
bad excuses
true
I am Giga gaming
we need a giga emote
all right if we get to 60 members I will
make a giga emote we're at 56.
we still gotta figure out what we're
doing at 100.
because I literally mentioned
memberships and everyone was like oh
yeah that's a thing
giga
I'm eating ham good for you that sounds
nice
there it is baby
Giga emote acquired
Twisted let's go
everyone spam W and chat for Twisted
just going absolutely insane today I
appreciate you thank you
they all knowing thank you thank you
thank you very very much now we just get
a bunch of alerts hello
www
I will fix that for tomorrow
you know what I could do is fix this my
good father secreted me but decided
himself
why does it keep playing it shouldn't do
this by the way
the renewals as well
[Music]
it's really weird
I
I fear for Father's life
they've since come for everyone at the
companions I escaped with
me
I think it's no different
I implore you would you mind taking a
letter to my phone Stan you got a gifted
member from drips
please
I just want him to be safe
dearly no I like alerts I just you know
it should say like
uh Twisted gifted five memberships
instead of just playing every membership
deliver it to my father that's what I
mean who remains in the castle
should I just fix it I think I can fix
it really quick hold on
I'm pretty goaded on the sticks when it
comes to this stuff chat like I'm just
kind of clean with it you know what I
mean
you know what I'm saying like I'm just
like pretty good
at uh what I do you know
as it's like already broken okay hold on
hold everybody hold
because it's kind of insane
uh okay so settings
member alerts
variation settings wind variation is a
gift
settings
uh
is five the lowest amount you can gift
immunity gift
requirement at least
five
okay
it's not the lowest oh yeah you can gift
one can't you
that's right
you can get one
gifted amount members
Bay of variation
save in the chat okay we're gonna test
it real quick I won't make you guys
spend more money than you already have
let's see it
it says gifted five members
Hoggers huge we fixed it let's go baby
we're the best we're that quick with it
oh the wall wiggle like you trying to
make your way up but up
speed up Gas Pedal Gas battle gas battle
saw 50 at once already no shot
if you're like Tim let's Hat Man
or you have just a poggers community
kind of like mine
foreign
a capital w
Crown a capital w
how do I do that with a crown
oh [ __ ] I have the thing open
okay that was my fault and we're good
we're good it will not Auto double play
now I'm I'm a good streamer
is it yo yozakit is that how you say it
Yo's a kid thank you for becoming a
tarnish three months in a row appreciate
you thank you welcome welcome
Pro streamer Pro streamer okay let's
beat this Knight's cavalry
wait what other bosses have we beaten I
have not been checking off the list at
all right now bro
uh oh okay so we beat
we beat pumpkin head
mad pumpkin head underneath Waypoint
ruins heck
uh is that the only other boss we've
been no we beat the dragon
what is the flying dragon egg heal dead
boom there we go baby
yes gundier has been dead for six years
I keep forgetting to make it night time
I am Melania blade of mcquella
and I have never known defeat
can you imagine one day I just say
maquella in a video
do you think people will get really mad
all right let's try the slicer
so it's like a sword damn
[Applause]
I can spam it
we're at 62 out of 100. from the left
side of the screen
people will get mad
good
I kind of like making people mad at this
point is that bad
okay rock sling not great here
blade of Michael
it's like my normal playthroughs though
okay how was this
decent FP
wow
chat are you kidding me with this thing
I can literally spam it
slicer is op dude holy crap
oh wait we can go up here and get
another memory Stone can't we yeah yeah
yeah yeah see how I'm already getting
distracted
[Laughter]
Google keeps suspending my payment
account any other way I can support the
channel you just be in here and being a
cutie is already a huge plus I
appreciate it
you just keep doing you
you just keep doing you
but the best way is to give me money
okay I'm sorry I'm just kidding
I'm not really though
but I might be
you know now you'll never know
you are pretty cute though I will say
yeah I know The Shield's good field is
very good okay there you are dead
[Music]
money money a YouTuber at heart yep
that's me
it is my job
but I have learned as a content creator
you just kind of you gotta have to bring
it up every now and then or people kind
of forget
yep I killed uh ghost dogs they were
already dead guys
right
already dead it's you know they're not
they're not really dying I'm not hurting
them
you know what I mean no I'm saying bro
okay another memory Stone acquired
because I'm just that kind of poggers
all right
now
we're gonna make Finn happy and we're
gonna go get all our [ __ ]
heyo leave a like guys okay yeah I I
don't really know how YouTube streaming
Works to be honest
but I think everything helps
watching the Stream
liking the stream becoming members to
the Stream
it's all helpful you do what you can
myself
c-o-m-g-r-a-t-s on 100K thank you man I
appreciate the 10 super chat thank you
very very much
it's very kind of you thank you thank
you
Dee's Quest is in the round table so
we're good for now
we got 171 here and only 107 likes
that math don't work chat that math
don't work
that ain't right
well thank you again Trump
thanks Stephen
put Deez Nuts
you can start it not the round table I
mean I already talked to D and he's in
the round table so we're good
what's called round table because the
table in the middle of the room is round
there's your lore
up up
lore acquired
boy
[Music]
foreign
death birds are weak to strike which is
the damage type of rock sling
that's good to know because they are my
least favorite enemies to fight in the
game is probably the death Birds
least favorite boss
obvious lore acquiring
um isn't there a staff we can get down
here
or do we already have like the best
staff in the game
we gotta kill the queen
Queen pump a rump whatever name is
over here
Queen pump for him
damn
bow to me bow to me [ __ ]
get on your knees that's what I thought
go back to horny jail
[Music]
the staff isn't worth it but I got
enough runes to level
about that
how about that
you think they stopped fighting because
there's there's simp queen died
is that the lore
but I just got out of horny jail well
that's what you get for being horny
immediately after you get out
that's what you get
Rich oh pilgrimage
I feel like I should do a video on all
the churches
they have very distinct names
can we talked to Melina
foreign
it's pickle Rick
hopefully that comes up in a second
there it is baby
it's pickle Rick
together
hello there I sincerely hope someone
knows the response how is it going guys
hope it has been a good end to the year
for all been busy getting my butt handed
to me in the coliseums so fun so much
fun man
it's all going good pickle Rick good to
see you thank you for the 10 super chat
you're a homie appreciate it hope you're
doing well
and thank you very much
you guys still playing the coliseums I
haven't played it in a while to be
honest with you
okay let's talk to Melina
but thank you again pickle Rick
you're the man
spoken Echoes
words of Queen America
who vanished long ago if you wish
I will share them with you
I'm interested in America's own words
then
after thy death
I will give back what I once claimed
return to the lands between
wage war
and brandish the Eldon ring grow strong
in the face of death
I have a question Warriors of my Lord
Lord Godfrey this just came to my brain
okay Trey thank you for the eight months
man I love you
thank you thank you thank you sir
I have a question
so we're in a church of radagon right
but there are words of Queen America
that linger here
if radagon is Queen America
when when Melania says in the words of
Queen America is this specifically
radagon talking here
potentially
[Music]
does that make sense
I think that's an interesting question
right
America would have easily been in the
church but it's a statue of radagon
it's pickle Rick
and who says we got no maidens right I
got my maiden right here bro
Melina is the waifu thank you pickle
Rick you're the man thank you thank you
thank you
yes and no
it's America it's just because Miss
begottens love radagon and hate on
America
where the [ __ ] is vati when you need him
I don't think body knows the answer to
that question I don't think anyone knows
the answer to that question because it
cannot be answered I'm just bringing up
what a question you know what I mean
I do think that's like too it's like an
unnecessary question you know
like we just gotta go with she said
Queen America so we're gonna go with
Queen America right
I think that makes the most sense and
should not overthink it once I started
doing that everything got a lot easier
to understand
so chat tell me to shut the [ __ ] up when
I ask questions like that okay
it's totally fine for you to tell me to
just shut up
I will go okay sorry
however it's a question that I'm gonna
ask but you can also tell me to shut up
does that make sense
it's not a boss down there is there
no I'm going to keep asking stupid
questions but you guys can tell me to
shut up that's all
silence
all right let's see how this goes I do
not like fighting these things but here
we go
oh boy okay so let's eat these out
Rock sling yeah really bro
oh
this weapon is ridiculous
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I couldn't remember what that did damn
it
[Music]
balanced gamer
do I put this on
that's a question
being Harry Potter is really easy mode
stand my character's name is Perry
hotter get it right thank you
cess
oh it doesn't help with any stats you
have through
how about every time you ask a question
you have to 1v1 one of us at random
well we'll be 1v1 all day all I do is
ask questions in this game
appreciate it man
[Music]
thank you thank you
everyone like the video let's get to 100
likes we're not at 100 likes yet
hello
what are we even doing here
I can get offline if that's what you
guys want I'm just kidding
red potato thank you I appreciate all
the super chats Chad thank you super
chats chat
we're decently past 100 all right we're
good then
we're at 165.
okay that's a lot of likes
and we get to 200 though probably not
unless we have 200 viewers which I never
know how many viewers we have by the way
I have no idea
no need to know don't tell me either
really
Jesus chat
I don't think I need to go in there
let's go over here and then we're gonna
update our boss list Stephen thank you
for the two dollars
you guys are being kind of crazy
thank you very much
phone don't update
why is mobile live stream live streaming
so weird
I feel like mobile is so always so bad
well there's been anything how can I
help
you have nothing I want
he has the zwie hander
I didn't know that's where I got this
cool
is this your most successful stream
in terms of memberships
yeah big time
I have streamed a lot this year
and we've gotten more memberships today
than we ever had
I just got to keep talking about
memberships apparently
okay where else can we get stuff chat
like are we good for now
should we go uh down here
yeah why not
let's go turn in our letter and
everything
I think YouTube hasn't figured out the
streamy thing
well I'll tell you YouTube mobile
streaming is way better than twitch
way better
and I'm I'm saying that from my own
experience
mention it every two minutes
but I don't want to be annoying
cat become a member
just go ahead and do it
pretty cool
I guess we gotta talk about what we're
gonna do at a hundred
because that's our first goal is 100 and
we're at 62.
this is a good number for like some type
of challenge run
we starting to get into the higher
numbers that's when we start doing
cosplays
where I gotta dress up as Ronnie or
something that'd be actually pretty cool
joystream
hmm I always always here though
no level up retro
I swear if I see that stuff if we get to
those numbers we will Stephen it will
happen I will look like Ronnie
or whoever you guys want
I'll get a red wig and no shirt put on a
towel and I'll be radagon
with my butt crack hanging out
no status effect run
you know what we could do is a run
um
saw a little Aggie do this where
every death
makes the game 10 faster
I'll just play the eldenbeast okay I'll
just go get a dildo
you just don't die you know
foreign
we could do that too Mike I've seen that
done before there's like a mod for that
every death increases new game with
uncapped new game pluses
uh there's a face that'd be ridiculous
Warden of this Castle probably Angel by
Lord godric himself but you can see how
things have turned out pretty bad a
little rebelled they gave me good
service or so I thought
but it seems it was all an act
foul creatures as it said and true
enough their foul inside and out I'm
sorry to disappoint you but whatever you
come here to do it's okay Daddy I'm
afraid Castle mourn won't hold much
longer take this by way of apology he
gives you a stick imagine
I see from Arena
thank you yeah he's a little racist
but I can't leave yet even if the castle
should fall as Commander I must remain
to ensure the treasured sword of mourn
does not fall into the wrong hands
if you see Arena do tell her her father
will come for her once he's fulfilled
his duty
her father okay
uh
uh day okay look at all this Blood oh my
God
her father
I will save I saw
um ratatosker
I'm sure you guys know who that is right
um
he made a video saying that lorenia
Lakes is the worst area in the game
I would argue that the Weeping Peninsula
is the most boring area in the game
where I'm at right now pretty much
I would say it's the most boring
I like urania Lakes personally
but this area is always raining and sad
and there's really like there's a good
amount going on but not a not a ton
it is the squirrel from God of War but
he's a YouTuber who does a lot of soul
stuff
pretty much go here once because it has
a lot of good upgrade material
and then we can get runes early really
easily here but that's kinda
time to it you know what I'm saying you
know what I'm saying guys like
it is what it is though
hear me do I even need this anymore like
am I am I going to use this staff for
the rest of the game
wasn't that video about speed runs I
don't think so
I think he was just talking about how
Lorena Lakes was just like a wasted area
like there's a lot of like nothing in
the entire like
no I know it's called weeping Lake I get
it it's just like I'm still I still
don't like it you know
foreign
but it makes sense to the theme like I
don't think they should have put
anything else here
I think it's good for what the area is
but I still don't like it
Rock sling
oh my God
now
roxling might be too slow unless I do it
like this
nice
[Music]
no I [ __ ] up
oh I should be done
you're a wizard Harry Potter
you're a wizard
too strong for any foul
too strong
for you
I think I've had it has just enough to
be exciting with the memory Stone Onyx
Lord minor archery watery Mona Lisa
Mausoleum I do hate the concert random
yeah it's just like I don't really like
rain
which is like a dumb reason to dislike
the area but you know what I mean like
it's it's my least memorable area
and I'd say next to that might be
mountaintops of the Giants
that area just seems like kind of
Unfinished to me
okay
let's see no we're gonna keep doing this
character I'm having a good time with it
hey who did we just beat
this is the not Lim grave it is
it is Lynn grave
and we just killed
we we killed the uh let me find the name
Leon Miss begotten dead
demi-human Queen
dead
ancient hero of zamor dead
I think that's it for now okay
gotta keep the list going you know what
I'm saying you know what I'm saying bro
um now where do we go
so I feel like I don't have a
do I really not have glass
I still have three three really
do we go kill godric
we definitely can
oh yes let's go do all that area yeah
let's go out this way
there's a rune bear boss in a cave and
weeping nitzela
yeah it's it's near uh where I killed
the the queen
yeah we're gonna go do blind we're gonna
go do Kenneth height
the whole shebang
who's your least favorite NPC in the
game chat
mine could be Kenneth height
let's go over to him
find a lamb
kinda racist
dude she eats eyeballs and throws up
that's awesome
I like nephelulu personally
[Music]
as stock
the guy in Stormville isn't that a
it's not s stock is it
where the hell is this man he's over
here
is he over here
I forget
I think he's way over that way
[Music]
Vare huh yeah vari's creepy
but I think he's like a good kind of
creepy like good for the got stuck
that's his name
he's a good kind of creepy evare
I like gostock just because he Stomps on
godric's head
I thought that was a neat Touch by the
developers to do that
dude gold mask yeah he's
I mean he doesn't talk
hello is anybody there
someone who might be interested in
rescuing the great Kenneth height I'm
right in front of you servant to the
true order and celebrated repudiator of
the false let me gas myself up
[Music]
he's like me when I ask for new members
it's very kind but um
no look how racist he was just now the
help is very much appreciated even from
a tarnished despite appearances nobility
is no prerequisite to serving the true
order
might have heard of me that's a really
good idea red mine is the rightful ruler
yeah read what red just said yeah I'm
tarnished I would have a boon of you I
want you to take back my fort
it lies to the Sun so we spin a wheel
every time and we level that stat based
on what the wheel spin is and Plum bad
to boot that's a great idea
dang are you still doing lore videos of
course what are you waiting for
kiss goodbye my fort lies to the South
Beyond The Mist wood do you guys want to
do that for me at 100 members
that would be a really fun stream fret
not the great Kenneth's height is known
for his considerable logic wheel of
levels yes
indeed upon the dawn of my fort's
retrieval
um yes allow me to furnish you with a
little advice
obsessed with sacrificing tarnished like
you for the sake of all right that's
what we're doing honestly we've decided
more than a jumped up country bumpkin
Lord oh don't make me laugh if we get to
100 members we will do the wheel of
level run then hit from Redan in that
castle
then he insulted Melania lost to her in
battle only to lick her boots rather
than die like a man
I won't forget that's too good of an
idea to forget girls blouse and to think
he's the blood of Godfrey last of the
golden lineage
you almost wouldn't know it to look at
him
yeah I almost feel sorry for the chap
the more I think of it
now gadget's a piece of [ __ ] what are
you waiting for
a kiss goodbye my fort lies to the South
Beyond The Mist wood
take it back for me
so what happens
foreign
members right now I'll push him off the
cliff
I'm being really member greedy today
just trying to figure out a way to get
people to do it
you get a golden seed I like that I like
that
all right there's one
well witness red coming in
appreciate it man welcome to the tarnish
good to have you bro
we get four more I'll push them off
he's gone
[ __ ] how do you gift
okay I'm not gonna go that far to tell
you
oh man
hmm
kill him I I put my price this ruins our
100 run if we do this
saying
we'll give it like another
20 seconds
there's two
oh man
you know you want it look look how he's
he's like what the [ __ ]
there's three
all right good enough good enough he's
gone
on all thank you Harmony and Van I
appreciate it three is good enough
three's good enough
and I have seen quite enough
Harmony van red appreciate you guys
thank you
you think you'll fall eventually
there's no way he gets back up here
right
it's no shot
wait
oh
there he goes yeah
[Laughter]
oh no he's dead
oh no
you guys did this not me
nice golden scene honestly worth
I've never killed him before that's
funny
all right thank you chat
you're the best
see I didn't do anything I pushed him he
he died
you know what I mean
it's not my fault
I don't know how he got on that side of
the cliff you know
yeah he died to gravity
you're locked out in a Philly I mean I'm
not locked out of nepheli but I am
locked out of the ending yeah
all right I wonder if she'll still go to
the end it's possible probably not
probably not but whatever
you guys have seen it it's really not
that great of a questline
spoken Echoes of Queen America
linger here as well you never let him
live ever Mike interesting
very well
in America's own words
my Lord
and thy Warriors I think it was just a
skill issue anti-fest each of the of thy
Grace
With Thine Eyes dimmed ye will be driven
from the lands between ye will wish
and I well yeah I know he gives you two
ancient sounds that might serve you
we're gonna be fine you really only need
one
maybe two
thanks Melina I love you what okay sorry
he could have jumped yup his AI doesn't
know how
is dummy thick
yeah we got all that that's good
that's good
all right let's go uh talk to bloid
and then I guess we can go do his uh his
Bloodhound Quest right
why not
I would never kill blood but kind of
tight I was definitely fine uh poking
him to the edge you know
now I didn't kill him
but yeah
did you get the snap emote
map
no that's my alert sound when somebody
subscribes
I'm gonna make a giga emote though
Giga well let me pick these up up here
we'll have to go to some minor trees as
well and get some of these these doodads
right here
oh well I have to go here to get the
snappy mode so we'll go back there
now we can go to church of Ella
and then he'll tell me
you guys act like I don't know
crazy
I can also that you're not then why not
I am Carl I am Carly the howl of a wolf
in the Mist wood
follows he must I'll just get the emote
if I kill Kali I would never kill him I
know
why not meet him for yourself he's a
sweetie next time you hear the wolves
howl make this signal right under the
source
don't fret there is nothing to fear I
just have an inkling the two of you
might hit it off we could do a run where
we just kill everyone in sight
that'd be interesting too goodbye for
now
okay
now there's like no good uh spot out
here
I'll just come from this way again
you can do things Jake we can't I mean I
kind of tell you what I I kind of do
what you guys tell me
I'm kind of at the whim to whatever you
guys want you know
it's really true
dice roll generator maybe use a to
assign a stat to a number pulled up on
screen to prove that you're stat pumping
assuming you're on PC of course I am on
PC yes we we could do that I was just
gonna get us like a a wheel spin and I'd
pull it up on screen
and then we just spin it
whatever stat it lands on is what we put
it in
that'd be really fun actually
we'll do that at 100 100 members chat
we only need 35 more
and we'll start that run at some point
I get lost in here okay there we go
oh [ __ ]
her emission activate we all know a
furry
oh no furry do you guys know furries
I do know how to call a furry
just like that thank you again pickle
Rick you're the man who goes there
okay
never the bloody busy body
hmm
maybe to him you don't seem so strange
his sword is so alive
I'm looking for a man who goes by
darywell he nervously walks around
also I've heard come tell me if you find
him before I do I agree red whoever
thought of the wheel spin idea is really
handsome
darrowell is nothing but a traitor and
in need of a fitting end to his tail
you're a wizard Harry hotter
all right let's go help him out
uh you would have made a build like mine
I spread my points first playthrough I
have at least 20 and all but 25 of my
highest I can kill anything
that's pretty cool actually who knows it
might turn into that
I'm the one he told red about it
oh I see I see
blushes
it's a great idea it really it really
really
is
foreign
hotter
nailed rotting in a cell is no true
Justice no this is where it ended oh my
God
I'm gonna let blind finish this one off
what do you guys think
oh [ __ ] he might die
okay
I'll finish this one
I have never seen blood get annihilated
like that
usually vlad's like super op
well at least he died in the spirit
world and not for real
you know what Daryl did to get blind to
kill him I'm pretty sure
darewell
was a part of like Ronnie's crew and he
betrayed them
let's get our somber too
right
there you are
not to work for it but it's done
oh they nerfed them huh
gives you a prize
thank you
oh yes
I should say NPC Purge played through
well he's not really dead come across a
venerable blacksmith who's a little on
the large side tell him I sent you until
we showed a treat you right Bloodhound
Knight derawill checked off
agreed
all right where do we go now do we go to
godric
and uh talk to
our boy Roger
blind's a pretty big boy
pretty tall
how tall do you think he is like if I'm
I'd say my character's like 5 10.
[Music]
like eight feet tall nine feet tall
probably nine feet
big boy
it's called a death bird ah
okay we can where's the death bird over
here
no no
right here
at least get the Lakes
I mean we can definitely kill godric
godric's a pushover bro
88-9 all right
uh okay
right night time nighttime nighttime
well
dude I hate fighting these things
they'll spawn right here right
no no it's over this way
My High
Maybe
oh
that was me that was me that was me
we're good
yeah
let me just pick these up
24 centimeters
what the [ __ ] is a kilometer
like for real who measures
who measures in centimeters
crazy people do that's what
it's right here
or over here there we go
[ __ ] you man
manga
it's hit me why is a ram going after me
man
are you kidding
whoa they are super weak
I didn't mean it I didn't mean it
why are these he killed the goats that
were helping them man
what the heck
oh
thanks for killing all your buddies
death bird
dead
get it
are you [ __ ] kidding me
yo what
come on
come on mess with me I'll mess with you
bro
why are you backing up now because
you're scared
talking all that [ __ ] online huh huh
yeah that's what I thought
[ __ ] all right uh
what is it called Death bird appears at
night on the ruined cupboard in ruined
fragment blue feathered Branch sword
boom that one
what's that talisman
raises defense when HP is low I feel
like that's actually pretty good for me
because I get low Health White
back on this character
okay
let's kill
godric
let's do it
this Ray guy to speak a nonsense chat
what's going on with this guy
all right
yeah I checked off the Ram oh wait
you know what I'm gonna go back to the
round table and like turn in all my crap
all my ruins it's so much quicker
upgrade Vigor dude I have to upgrade
upgrade int though
I'm a wizard
you're no matter loud you I don't mean
to skip his uh stuff but you know here
we are
I have 13 of these
how many runes that just give me 21.
so we finish
um Roger's questline I can get his
weapon and then take his Ash of war from
it correct
I'm getting my into 20. okay I think
that's fair
price Noob okay I'm just gonna ban this
guy because he's weird sorry
you're just kind of weird bro
all right now we go kill him
what is completionist doing every
questline and every boss in the game
you can't take it but if you replace it
you lose it
uh the ray guy got banned
weird fatting
I like people who actually like to talk
and not just say random [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying
a rusting sword
but you get the uh this glint so glint
blade Phalanx and we can put it as an
ash of War right or can we not do that
come over here would you
you your eyes
well yeah Height's dead well but of
course
bye bye
yeah Rey's dead
or he's banned
a sword that automatically comes with
yeah I think I get what you guys were
saying
I think
here I'll get this over here too so that
we can uh use godric's great room
afterward
FF wyoku that's what I heard
it's at plus eight yeah we're not gonna
use it though
it can't be applied to staffs
you put it on a dagger or something did
I put it on my shield
actually I'd probably want to get a
dagger and put it in my left hand right
what would what would Harry Potter do
no way
I thought I died I'm dead
holy [ __ ]
stop shooting me
you keep shooting me
ah
ask Hermione
not Perry hotter's parents are alive
uh-oh I got lost
because it's dark
foreign
[Music]
thank you Jesus
get reduvia we already have raduvia and
we're not going to use it obviously
this is a wizard playthrough sir
what are you crazy
did we talk in a felly or no
it's the Nintendo switch snap
I'll go talk to her if she's there I I
don't know if killing
kind of tight
would do that
these birds are just
that one lagged into me and you all saw
it too you all saw that that was crazy
wait is nepheli gonna die
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] to the higher place
a felly stayed back there
oh God okay
okay they're dead
I feel like right there would have been
good for a pebble you know yeah
tarnished are you
clearly not one of God wait we gotta go
talk to uh Lou yeah we gotta go talk to
Roger Gloria like right I'm here by
decree of my father how utterly
repellent this is this grafting of
godric's ill befits the Lord he's
tainted the very winds
if you intend to challenge godric good
enchant weapons upon me yeah chat voted
to uh eat him off a cliff certain father
would permit me ate the fight yeah we
got to go back into Stormville if we
want to talk to Roger
foreign
do we do that
I know it's due
I'm smart watch
and talk to him at the round table Yeah
but I want to talk to him before
it's like more immersive
I feel like since I decided to be a
wizard it's just been night time the
entire game
I've made it nighttime
to kill uh some things
okay so we got that spot now we're gonna
go back
[Music]
yeah I don't need that
[Music]
didn't I call this up
oh I see
okay
we go down there
I command the pew pew
yes Ludwig
of course
I command thee to peel pew
immediately
the pope has spoken
night sorcery is the best against
Melania
what's considered night sorcery
like mist
like mist and [ __ ]
see
another two
oh Ronnie's Dark Moon yeah yeah I got
you I got you I got you bro
where does this go
I'm gonna live chat I don't know where I
am right now
I know where I am
I figured it out I'm smart
does mikola use Melania as his sword
you mean Melania blade of mcquella hmm
potentially
potentially yes
okay
the beauty of a sorcerer build right
here
look at that I did not have to even deal
with the bird
look at that
like you're literally cheating if you're
using a sorcerer build I'm sorry you're
cheating
you're a cheater
like what
was the scariest part of the game for me
when I play it with my big sword
is there a crucible night here
I don't think so
there's one outside
[Music]
ah nice to meet you hello the pleasure's
mine I like his voice actor
a sorcerer as you might have guessed
you're cheating playing the game right
in the castle I'm kidding when I say
that from the troops that is but enough
about me
what are you doing here in stormvale
Castle this place is bristling with
tarnished Hunters you know
they sacrifice Our Kind
for grafting not exactly a place I'd
stroll into without a purpose in mind
I'm here to defeat godric I see here to
challenge godric and lay your hands upon
a great Rune are you you can see it then
I take it the guidance of Grace well
enjoy it while you can I'm tarnished
like you but unlike you I've seen
neither hide nor hair of this guidance
for the longest time
still
I won't forget how it felt when I first
came here to the lands between I'm privy
to a few magical battle Arts would you
care to learn one as a fellow tarnished
once Guided by Grace I'd love to help
you out if it please and I I hate using
magic because I don't like the long Gap
and just Spam sorceries over again it's
no fun I love the smash and slash my
opponents to death
that's what I usually do but I've never
played like this so I'm doing it do I
need any of these chat we already have
this right or is this a bigger one
oh and it has that okay well we're we
talk to him we're good okay chat I'm
gonna go get a drink real quick and then
I'm gonna go pee
um and then I'll be right back
um if I came back to like 100 members
that'd be cool just saying all right
I'll be right back
BRB BRB
take a break
small break
[Music]
remedy
together
he's gone everyone talk bad about Jake
[Music]
foreign
together
I heard that Jake was a puppy squeezer
and a puff pastry hangman
okay I'm back
hello
why are you saying I smell I don't
he's gone everyone talk bad about Jake
bro
dude
none of y'all became members but you but
you super chatted
I heard that Jake was a puppy squeezer
and a puff pastry hangman I don't even
know what that means
so it can't be true
but Tater and Ludwig thank you I
appreciate it
okay
I'm sorry I thought you wouldn't see
that I see everything
[Music]
did Roger do anything weird while I was
gone
would be in a spell break spellblade
break the wizard theme
I feel like we could do it you know what
I mean
thank you
I feel like we could get a sword in our
left hand
right
by the way I was talking to my dad our
older dog Marley
apparently fell down the stairs like a
little while ago
and like her back hurts and we're kind
of trying to figure out what to do so I
was kind of checking on her by the way
let's use nepheli
our dog the Marley's like
she's like 15 years old Chad they're the
true born air
lend me thy strength o Kindred very old
I really can't really see
well
carry a night sword could work we'll see
we'll see how it works out
if you guys say it won't ruin the build
then we can use it
hello guitarist
yep Boomer like me playing as a lord
come on
I'm the Lord of all yeah this looks kind
of cool at night
looks really cool at night actually
oh
rocksling
I have never seen him do that so early
you can't say that yet
hey thank you Martin I appreciate it man
thank you very much dude
welcome to tarnish two months now
whoops
did Martin do that on purpose by the way
godrics in my opinion one of the best
bosses in the game
he's really [ __ ] cool I love his
music as well
ah truest of dragons
lend me thy strength
yeah
[Applause]
we've got her in a spot Bells it's okay
she'll be okay
[Music]
you almost got it Matt you almost got it
that was definitely on purpose you
almost got it
that was so close
damn bro
all right we're gonna slice them up boys
thank you again Matt and Martin and
Ludwig and red appreciate you guys
[Applause]
that's an easy boss [ __ ] ass Bubba boo
good stuff good stuff wait why can't I
leave okay now I can
let's go get our great room
easy money bro
well like why are the people in this
chat cultured so much
um because my community
slaps
press one and chat if you agree
my community is the best
yep marking it off the list
that's a dead boy
I've never used a rune Arc
I very rarely use a rune art
wait what just died over there what the
heck
we're all just gigas
and if I had a freaking Giga emote we
could be spamming that right now
you see all this dodging by the way is
this not just impressive
it's like I played this game a lot
great runes are mid I agree however
they're a fun addition
he wasn't even in my MTV Cribs
I love HP bomber guys videos by the way
let's go Taryn let's go
wait we're at 67 members now holy [ __ ]
we've gotten like 40 members today by
the way that's crazy thank you guys
our chat is a sea of green now it's nice
I wish you could change the color do you
guys wish you had your own customizable
colors for the chat room are you cool
with just being Gray
because I guess the gray is clean but
I don't know I kind of like the
different colors
and then you could show your membership
with the badge that's next to your name
if you are
I wish I was red
you have your own on Twitch yeah that's
that's what people like you know like
you you can customize yourself a lot
more on Twitch than you can here
I mean I know that uh
should I live on my decks at all by the
way um I'm just gonna level in the uh
I don't remember what I was talking
about
I think the gray is meant to incentivize
people to donate but people don't have
that like they're not gray on Twitch and
people donate and give subs and become
Subs all the time on Twitch there's a
huge culture of that on Twitch
anyone who's become a member today or
wants to become a member make sure you
go to the community Tab and join the
Discord or members only Discord that's
where we have our fight club
we fight against each other in the
Coliseum it's pretty fun
we did that a couple weeks ago and it
was actually really fun you guys can do
that one whenever you want by the way
enhances charged attacks temporarily
boost stamina I mean
that's fine
make more mods
I don't really need more mods you know
what I mean
I think mods scare people
okay now
I'm in a mark off our boy
gogic the grafted good stuff chat
okay
where do you guys want to go now
[Music]
no cross yeah I know bro but the more
members we get in there the more people
can play against other people who are on
the same console
yeah I guess lorenia is next we could go
to um round table and talk to Roger
oh we need to go underneath storm bill
as well
well we don't really get anything cool
out of that we don't we get an apostle
ah we meet again after all it's like
pretty much a lore item guys for any
offense given by my bearing but I'm
quite unable to move you see so
what do you need I don't think we're
supposed to go to Caleb yet ah you
defeated godric and claimed yourself a
great Rune hmm looks like we both got
what we want it's a lore item didn't we
well done friend something to Mark the
occasion
go on take it
there it is do we use this I think we do
as you might have guessed I still can't
move
my fighting days are behind me no need
to be polite we'll go down there you
guys seem to want to go down there so
we'll go down there we'll beat that boss
too
okay I think we're good on that
um Okay so
let's do this staff in this hand
oh I can't even use it I need 17 decks
holy titties
damn okay
well we'll do that
we'll we'll upgrade our decks let's go
down there
uh
yeah
I hate mods my mods are really nice
until you're mean to me and then they're
not nice to you
I'm doing your playthrough
I mean I've never done a build like this
before it's actually more fun than I
thought it would be
whoop I forgot to grab that [ __ ] all
right whatever
we love Stan
here's the thing though Stan's been
around for years guys
years on Twitch
so it's hard to become a mod
who are mods Trey who I've known since I
was five we've got Cole who's been
around for years metal have been around
for years Stan
pile same thing years
whoops
what
dude I hate these things man
foreign
[Music]
I literally couldn't back up enough
foreign
oh we get a seed from him okay that's
that's actually worth
definitely worth bro
dude 100
Ludwig a hundred percent
I don't know a single person who likes
those bosses
like at all
right let's get our useless item
and then watch Roger get
death rooted
Eve
so does that entail that this thing's
alive
he's got a booger
I think that flew from over there
like I wonder if he can like move his
eyes to go up here you know I mean
I mean if he can like
morph around
yeah
creepy man creepy okay let's uh go back
here
amazing nostril ahead amazing
amazing
should I go duplicate this
yes right
let's do it
I already know the answer it's yes
I think there's a good dagger up the
ladder just teleported away
I mean I have that Rapier
yeah we're duplicating
for the stuff
for the Rooney boys
[Music]
I think that's all it takes
foreign
can you fall please
nope I gotta do more
I thought you only do one on this one
I guess it's two
oh Godwin is not mindless at all
like he is
definitely alive in his way you know I
mean
he just doesn't have a spirit his body
is just going ape [ __ ]
I didn't know that Mike it's pretty cool
but yes he is soulless
but his body
continues
which uh is kind of scary don't you
think
do you think we'll learn about the more
souls demigods in DLC
I have no idea they could go down so
many routes it's like impossible to say
what they're gonna do
I think it's literally impossible to say
what they're gonna do with DLC
it's Limitless potential for DLC
he does grow like a cancer I think
that's a good way to put it it is like a
cancer yeah
guys do we do decks are you okay with
this I think Dex is good for Source
rebuilds anyway right
so that we can um
ask spells faster
no
do dicks
well I have to upgrade decks to even use
the Rapier
no Stan we've done strength build so
many times
we need 18 decks
don't level decks radicon's icon will
give you 40 decks in the spellcast time
okay
so int then
bathe int you actually need faith
what do we need faith for
you y'all all over the place bro
okay let's think
we want to use this
it's Dex basically a death decks weapon
Vigor or decks don't I definitely don't
need faith
we're a wizard not a religious wizard I
don't know
I think it could be a first anniversary
thing Ludwig yeah
Prince of death stuff
okay well let's put on this that you
guys told me not to put on earlier wait
what does this do Vitality poop
this will give me 15 decks we need 18.
so let's get that to 18.
right
so level up
how many more do I need two
or one box I already forgot
15 we need 18 we need three
zero no scar seal
what are you guys talking about bro
one two three
and then ends
[ __ ] it we can change this later if we
want but now
I can use this
and this
if I do this
do this
pass back and now we got both
okay cool
and then these stay cool
um spells don't need that anymore
um
well I didn't want to get rid of that
dude
uh that
what's CR is Crystal burst good
it don't matter those are the two I'm
gonna use for right now
okay
I like it
craving to the Bone pushing me about
like that and after all that crafting oh
hello there
one member and I'll kill this guy
godric was always looking down on me he
got what he bloody deserve thanks to you
I'll tell you though what goes around
comes around he had an ugly heart an
ugly a countenance and met the ugliest
of ends hey
oh my God he didn't do anything yes he
did
he steals your stuff he steals your
runes if you die
let's freaking go rob oh Father foreign
let's go
oh my God
[Music]
what
like I can do what I like
ready ready
[Music]
what I gotta say about that
it's wasted thank you for gifting a
member to Brian and then Brian
welcome
it's good to have you here Rob thank you
as well
thanks for the membership guys are we
yep we're at 69
let's go thank you guys I appreciate it
that's a lot of members today a lot
I'll try and give you guys incentives to
to become members and get new members
I'm trying here but that that
spin the wheel run is actually a really
[ __ ] good idea that I would like to
do
so let's get to 100 at least sometime
this week
probably gonna be streaming most of this
week so
be on lookout for that
there she is
oh chat do we talk to Bach
you want to talk to Bach
we could help him
wasn't gossack a part of Kenneth's
questline I don't think so also Kenneth
is dead we killed him too
we uh we murdered him
all right let's go find our boy
not gonna lie I forget about Bach all
the time
should I make a video on Bach
I feel like I should
who's Kenneth
exactly
I will not hurt mock I don't want to
you you there you there could you help
us out Kelly
four
trying to help you man oh yes I remember
some Claude turned me into a tree you
were just breaking the spell weren't you
I was
the name's Bach I was pushed out of the
cave
told not to come back yeah why is Bach a
tree ended up as a tree
lucky you came along really
there's the lore guys he was kicked from
his group and then suddenly he was a
[ __ ] tree oh
why we'll never know when they threw me
out of the cave they took everything I
owned and so this is all I have to
express my thanks I hope you can forgive
me
I'm over here or if you can afford to
wait for a while
I could sneak back into the cave and
bring back something of actual value
then I'd be of some real use 10 biggest
mysteries in Elder ring
why is bark a tree right but I'll need a
moment I'm okay I'm frightened let's go
over here and help him out right guys
we're nice aren't we we're a nice
tarnish we we help those in need
we're a helpful Perry hotter
hot was box mom
God can you imagine that's funny
I feel like people would click on that
and go what the [ __ ] are you doing Jake
I have made one meme video before though
the Rick
didn't you kill someone nope I don't
know what you're talking about I'm the
best
I'm literally so nice to everyone
didn't we kill two innocent people I
mean I did it for money doesn't that
count for something
what do you need I don't want any
trouble what do you have
nothing well done yeah
I did it for money it's my job okay
it's my job guys
dostock was innocent no he was not also
rob you paid me to do it
hurts oh wasn't innocent I'm dyslexic
what are you doing here
my bad my bad place at once
they'll rush in and beat you yeah
Kenneth jumped and gostock is not an
innocent boy just like me
oh
he's such a [ __ ] it might mean for
saying that
he's such a [ __ ] dude
he's so tiny he just shouldn't be here
man
all right let's get our boy out here too
are we ready for this
probably not but here we go
foreign
one of my least favorite fights in the
game man I'll tell you what right now
he's dead
foreign
get out of here
[Music]
he has gravity magic too that's cool
you guys haven't seen the summit
all right we helped him
dual wielding rapiers ah that goes away
from our build too much I think
foreign
you just killed a family yeah who beat
up
Bach
oh wait
watch his face here stop what I think it
is his face freaks me out in this part
bro
my sewing needle
look at this
so weird
what made you go into a thing like that
my mum was a seamstress and that sewing
kick was all I had to remember are by I
always wanted to be just like sweet old
mum
well then I how hot was box mom I can't
just curl up and die can I
that would be such a meme video
you can't help it I know I'm I'm mean
mad gamer I'm sorry
I'll be more nice
however
um press one in chat if you think box
mom is definitely a MILF
uh terserated for tercerated I don't
know how to say your name I'm sorry
about that but thank you for becoming a
great room two months let's go bro
thank you thank you that got us to 70
members
70. let's freaking go dude
we were at like 27 at the beginning
that's big that's a big day
Rapier justification is the ash just
like yep I agree
totally agree
I won't kill more of the family here
69 gone well might as well get to 100
now right
imagine
okay
that's where we want to be
damn
you know what's stronger than Godfrey
family
yes
and family beat all the Elden Lords
really
all right
ulcerated I got you bro thanks again for
the membership I appreciate you dude
welcome welcome all serrated
I'm dyslexic and can't read hell yeah
bro
okay it's cool to have that here we got
it
very poger wager Smile as you know
all right
now box should be over here I believe
how many playthroughs have you done oh
my God I I cannot imagine
I think my my first character I've
gotten to like new game plus 20
something I'm not even kidding
I've done like 20 plus playthroughs with
that character
hello
is someone there
my name is hayata
and I'm journeying in search of the
distant life ulcerate alternated I'm so
dyslexic I'm sorry it's in your
possession to me altercated it has been
weak since birth you see
I can't tell which way I'm supposed to
go next like I'm serious when I say that
one of those grapes
kill her it will lead me
is a finger mating now I like her
questline a lot bro
if we get to 85 I'm gonna make it that
big 85 members
give a shibiri grape many thanks to you
now I can feel the distant light once
more you are most kind indeed hyena took
over the body of Irina chat
oh shoot
should we have talked to our boy
you are most kind indeed May the
blessing of the fingers be upon you
I gave her a grape he has the Grape let
me go down here I wonder if we can even
talk to uh
Edgar
hey have a good one Trump
yeah hayata is Irina yes they look
they're gone
her body's still here though
he's dead
[Laughter]
how do you become a member it's linked
in the description it'll say join the
agency
or to say it'll say join underneath the
stream you click on that
the body isn't real
fake bod
um where where do we fight him at here
Dad
isn't it like over here
or something
or over here
let's go let's go kill that
left of subscribe
who who did we just kill chat did we
even fight a boss just now no right
no
we're good
yeah Revengers Shack this way
or I'm thinking of the wrong Shack
I keep restarting at malakath because he
scares me
malacath is very hard
very
oh this is war Master isn't it
could we fight the the dude that's here
just like you let me ask you something
halfway up left side of lorenia got us
between to take up the fight gotcha does
your faith in the guidance of Grace Hold
firm despite the collapse of the golden
order
my faithful
yes you're a tarnished through and
through yes I asked me back
that's a quality needed now more than
ever any interest in bearing the torture
of my battle Arts all I know is this
unless you want his armor picked up a
fair few tricks we get runes dude Now's
the Time to pass them on
to a good and proper tarnished like you
we are detecting I appreciate it thanks
man
did you know that Senator Armstrong and
Amir have the same voice actor I did not
wait what mayor
God damn it
not floating your boat eh no well
there's no rush
knowledge of the Arts can wait another
day
thank you PT
okay let's make it night time
okay
and then I get up
and then I sit down
right
nope this doesn't work
I swear dude sometimes
the triggering these dudes just makes no
sense
maybe now I sit down
and then I make it nighttime
and then I get up
and then I sit down
nope
we just can't do it
all right we'll do that later let's go
uh lorenia
let's get it let's get it let's get it
let's get it let's get it let's get it
let's get it
fast travel during night does it uh-oh
okay
uh let's talk to our boy
wait box not here why is he not here bro
okay now I'm gonna go back because I'm
just curious now
you missed so much Brandon everything
nope okay now I sit down
or something
nope okay I don't know we're out of here
come back later
it's okay Phoenix so you don't have to
hey I've been wanting to visit Portugal
did we I definitely exhausted box
dialogue I bet if I sit down and get up
he'll be here
there he is
good to see you Master do you remember
me
but Bach the demi-human you helped me
before and retrieved my sewing needle
please master
viewer as your seamster I have you guys
ever used box
I'm happy to make adjustments to your
garments
I'll grave nice speeches sounds good to
me don't tell me master I was wondering
do you ever make adjustments to your
Garb yourself
wants just to try you let me do the job
when possible please I have to buy
something in return you know
I am your personal seamster after all
oh
we're going so soon but please don't be
safe on your Journeys I pity this dude I
pity him
have you seen the ending of his
questline though Ludwig it's pretty
intense to be honest I like his
questline once you take it to the end
now let's talk about the most useless
NPC in the game
this guy you're tarnished
let's make a bald guy with a beard who
dies in the oh you studied the next
place you see him
for a small donation
I'd be happy to share my knowledge
sure well bless you bless you you're a
true Saint my name is topes I did I
forgot his name till now oh I can teach
you sorceries as promised only
none of them are particularly great
[Laughter]
there are
not very good
geez friend I'm afraid my meager
sorceries are no match for your
generosity all right
I can tell you what I know about this
place
that should correct Brian you've seen
that structure to the north towering
over the world tell him
75 members and I'll kill him right now
sorceries only its doors have been
closed for we need five now after they
declared they wouldn't interfere and
I'll smack his bald head Academy cast
repelling seals on the East Gate leading
to the capital and the south gate
leading here as you might have guessed
this
lucrative making entry to the academy
impossible without a glintstone key and
so I'm stuck here this guy's a hobo a
fledgling sorcerer with little chance of
acquiring a key when they cast The Seals
his sorcery sucks just popped out
and now I'm uprooted from my place of
learning all right
about selling you've taken
it well that is something
selling was well known
the most promising Sorceress in the
history of the Academy I followed her at
school
he just wanted to be a wizard between us
sallen was expelled from the academy
accused of Unthinkable treatment
you guys under the name of the group do
five more members I still don't believe
the accusations if not I'll leave
selling would never do such things
foreign
however I am bopping him on the head
yeah I bet that hurt [ __ ] all right
let's continue
[Laughter]
man this game is so [ __ ] good bro
press one and chat if you agree
going back
pops gives Reddit energy no no no no
who gives Reddit energy
Gideon
Gideon gives me Reddit energy
ever since I had that giant Fiasco with
Reddit I have completely been off that
website for the last eight months in my
life has been significantly better
it's not a scroll it is a scroll
Reddit Ama
it's an Academy's role
look at these guys looking around for me
a little bunch of dummies
yep Gideon's the real antagonist
I hate that app too
oh yeah
they all knowing
Zeta wants a chat oh no
Zeta Our Father
witness oh no okay I gotta skip these
okay Zeta thank you very much for the
five members that's very kind of you
very kind I have to go murder him now
Chad I said I'd do it
I said I'd do it I'm gonna go do it
dude three people just renewed their
memberships right on the spot by the way
[Music]
Zeta get some W's in the chat for Zeta
that's big
thank you very much
you already left them alive
it happened I said 75 and we're in
nandez Obito and nuke Jaws thank you as
well I think they're not here and it's
just resubs but I appreciate it thank
you
all right guys
it's time
okay
I'm embarrassed
look at him using cover
I'm using cover too
he goes oh
he does decent damage actually
it's time to slice it Up chat
foreign
remember to join the Discord guys if you
did and thank you for reminding them
Zeta if you are now a member thanks to a
gifted membership or whatever it is make
sure you go to the community Tab and you
can join the disc or the members only
Discord
make sure to do that
thank you again Zeta
who do I suggest to Jake kill most of
these seats
I wouldn't do it if you guys didn't give
me incentive but here we are doing it
here we are
now you're the Eldon Lord
yes we defeated the most powerful you
plan doing PVP stream on Sunday
I think we're just gonna do those at
random
also excuse my burp
um you guys can do that whenever you
want
I don't have to be streaming
for you guys to like get in the Discord
and want to fight against each other and
try builds and stuff but I I do plan on
doing that I just don't know if it's
going to be like every Sunday
25 more and you hit your goal yep and
we're gonna do that that Fun Run
absolutely
okay what more did we get here
nothing we really want
I want to level dude I'm so close to
leveling
whatever we'll get it okay
is the screen blurry yeah it's a depth
of field you see that right there like
the background gets blurry but my
character gets uh
more Sharp
it's like one of the mods so if I look
over there then it won't be blurry but
now it is look down here
if I'm looking directly at it then it
blurs
it's for immersion man
only 10 more for Dead Eye lady I will
kill hyetta if we get 10 more members
he will die
that [ __ ] with my eyes I can turn it
off if you want
I personally like it because it looks
good
[Music]
foreign
but you see that how it's all blurry in
the background there and then I think I
turned it off like this
nope that made it a lot worse
see that
so that's when it's cranked up all the
way and it gets all shaky
oh God it won't turn off
it won't turn off
wait okay there we go now it's off
get off the damn horse
[Music]
oh you're saying when I go in here that
I'll get a bunch of good sorceries
where are the good sorceries in here
I think it's my screen okay well make
sure you up the quality my friend
it's on you and your internet
oh yeah common Azores in here huh
is that really still super good
I thought I got nerfed but maybe it
didn't I'm dead
I messed up
I uh
I messed up
oh Azure yeah yeah
I remember you guys were talking about
we want Terra Magicka right
that's like actually super good
I bear witnessed it
Jesus
is this Dragon gonna be really hard to
kill well no I have Rock sling which is
physical
so we're good
the cave below Raya Lucario yeah
Raya Lucario
okay we'll go we'll go in there
let me go over here and I think we can
talk to d'elos over here right
isn't the yellows over here
you know what I think the alos is my
second least favorite character in the
game
I think he's just kind of a [ __ ]
but we might want him for the uh for jar
jar Barn
yeah he's over here
could be
is he further this way
jarberger
I forget where this [ __ ] doofus is
Ida loss
be written in blood
I'm lost I'm lost I don't know where I
am
stuck in a tree
oh
I swear he was like right around here
[Music]
maybe he wasn't exactly East
whoa
am I being a forehead right now
what's going on
no dalos is not
these brother that's somebody else
Juno haslow is dialos right
got the Christmas strategy book volume
one had no I haven't gotten it now
I have not gotten it
chat
he's like right here right
maybe I do no I'm pretty sure I don't
have to talk to him at the Round Table
I'm like 99 sure
that's his older brother right right
thank you
correct
Z
you should talk to him first I mean I
know I should but he I know he's here
I'm just not looking in the right spot
is he more like this way
to the least
foreign
I mean there can't be something
attacking me
because he's in a spot where you don't
get attacked
foreign
oh my God
this is annoying
I could have swore
is that a Grace
oh that's the one I just had dude I'm
I'm literally lost bro
I think rather tusker had it right when
he said this area was the worst
I think really the other side of the
school all right I'm cutting right
through
just let them be nah
is he over here
no no he's not he's not on the other
side of the school
definitely over here
I mean maybe maybe I do have to talk to
him ice Coulda swore you don't
but I could be wrong
all right well let's go let's go let's
go prove it let's go figure it out
he's right there being a little [ __ ] as
per ush
ER ah hello
I don't know why I don't like him I just
don't well just call me dialos the owner
of one's house holds little Import in
these lands by the way
have you met a young woman named lanya
on your travels she's my servant is he
really Angel there was the wind take
your eyes off her for but a moment and
she's good I guess I was thinking of the
wrong one
please be sure to tell me
okay
so he is not here
but he'll be over this way
looks like Jon Snow just a 10 000 times
less cool yeah exactly
I'm the lore guy I should know where he
is
I'm sorry Chad I'm letting you down
right now
I should know everything about this game
at this point shouldn't I
why is this crab right here
oh man this area is really pretty huh
at certain times of the day
it's really not possible in this game
but
I could be better for you I swear
I will be better
you guys ever wonder like what's in here
the light that shines off it is really
weird
thank you
dude where is this guy
we'll get faster life
no
no
they viewbot their streams [ __ ] them
he's got to be right here like my brain
will finally lift from this fog whenever
I [ __ ] see him
is anyone else like me like I just I
have to do it before I can do anything
else
oh my God thank you
there he is
answer me would you
oh
hello friend tell me if you know would
you the whereabouts of the Hidden House
of those despicable fiends the recusents
who hunt their fellow tarnished volcano
manners upon my servant lanya and I
refuse to let the insult stand the tale
of house hoslow is told in blood
idealos swear to deliver the message oh
it started raining as you said that
that's kind of cool
they laid hands upon myself okay
all right at least now I know where that
is
thank you
chat you're the best
you're just so cool
all right
do I try and kill
I'm confused okay there we go the Dragon
isn't this Dragon magic resistant
what
they're not physical magic resistant
wow
probably should be facing it huh
[ __ ]
really good damage
move it
we're cutting it close there boys we're
cutting very close there
foreign
hotter
defeats another foe
it's just too easy for him
if you watch other lore content I do not
at all
nope
my latest video I talk about that for a
little bit
and it's been for the betterment of my
mental health
I wish I didn't have to do that I really
don't but I do not watch any other Elder
ring content at all
it's been better for me
but you all should
because Smoketown bati everybody they
make Banger content
Harry Potter
is any mini in the game 100 resistant to
stat build up
I don't know I'm not sure
nothing I'm aware of
int
ENT
occasional exceptions
um
not recently no there's been like
actually no exception
and I've just been like a happier guy by
doing it
it's just how I be
um I would imagine radagons completely
resistant to like holy damage right
okay that oh God that's scary
this is such a cool like setup
wow that was [ __ ] great
damn son
oh no
what the [ __ ]
see I think that's good for you Taryn
but for like
for me as a Creator it's not
it just twists my brain into a bunch of
different places that I just can't deal
with
unfortunately
I got big brained I think I just need to
stab him
all right I got an idea
a little bit of that
you know a little bit of this a little
bit of that
what
I did nothing
damn
I watched a lot of Zoli
but I have since not
I really don't watch like I'm serious I
don't watch any Elven ring YouTube
content at all
maybe someday that won't be the case but
for now I kind of have to do that
everything's weird when you're a Creator
chat everything
there we go
ow dude these guys Farm
where are you
now what
all right whatever
I need to get that uh night lamp
a lighter whatever
is there a secret area down here at all
I don't think there is is there
I think Zoli I've seen Zoli on Twitter
um she's displaying Pokemon and I think
just enjoying her break
sometimes you gotta take a step back bro
dude this ain't easy when I'm against
other Wizards man where am I [ __ ]
I mean I unfollowed everyone on every
platform
so I just occasionally see tweets but
nothing like uh
I don't follow anybody on anything
I wish I didn't have to do but I do
there we go
that was a big boy
no shot that actually hit me
Rune Arc I can finally use my great room
getting pissed from school drop out got
your phone taken away take theirs they
suspended you suspend them
right
I need magic that has some distance
and doesn't take forever
he'll even need to fight this guy let's
go away
yeah I could use Pebble couldn't I
think these things are so weird
thank you
I can't see the other one but hopefully
we're okay
I love how they explode
wait I get Terra Magica after these guys
right
thank you
okay dude
carrion slicer is ridiculous
and we got a release spell that's big
that's big big big boy
I'm kind of having fun being a wizard
games a lot seems easier to be honest
but
that's cool Finn
yeah that was that felt like an hour ago
Finn
you know how it like it took me an hour
to like go to get upgrades for my flask
because I got distracted 75 times
is that like the barrier around the
academy by the way like that aura
all right this is a big pickup right
that's a big pickup
okay
good stuff chat
let's go
did I pick up the key
behind the dragon I don't think I did
hmm
there's an Easter egg if you jump off
shut up Mike
it's called Death
you did well now I don't trust you
okay I did nice
I don't think we go there yet do we
Ronaldo might be one of the harder boss
fights in the entire game
right Lord frog quad right exactly
of course
where's Revengers Shack
oh yeah Rock sling will actually kind of
Annihilator won't it
that's just kind of how I am print
I'm kind of weird
Rock sling doesn't work use more rock
sling
so the exact opposite way I'm going huh
okay let's go that way
you need to get more flasks
you need
to
stop being so cute
how about that
got him
at least show how the Auburn Oregon was
in the castle with the hands
that's right
you stop being so damn cute
you guys don't know if I'm cute or not
you don't know what I look like
I could be butt ass ugly
I could be butt ass
it's sick
I have that spell
yeah you guys don't know what I look
like
y'all don't know
all right what do I look like then
what do I look like
I like how his are bigger
kind of linger
like you'd be named Jake
foreign
Potter Harry Potter
just got even better
wait was that a better Phalanx spell
is that literally just bigger phalanx
me all right let's keep going this way
you drink green milk
it was not green milk it was a smoothie
but how do you guys know I don't look
completely different now
don't
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
where's the shack at
put that cam up
if we get to 100 members I'll start
using a camera again and we'll do that
uh spin the wheel run
there's a lot of goats here
how about that
it was there all right we're going here
first
I don't know Chad told me to go south so
I went South bro
through Mike good point
you're like 35 in on a level 44 is kind
of nuts
this looks just like the statue in the
coliseums doesn't it did they just rip
it out of here
[ __ ]
your addition guide thee did I say that
right
what the [ __ ] does that word mean
what was that noise did you all hear
that
the quality of having or showing great
knowledge or learning
scholarship
he was known for his wit
iridition and teaching skills
the tops gesture
foreign
as you wish right no no
which one was the tops one
is it this one
like as you wish
or is it actually just called your
Edition
oh I missed it
ah [ __ ] bro
about
I thought I got it from killing him
base reveal win 100 members I'll start
using a camera again
we need 25 more
use air Edition no kidding
do you have any idea how many words are
used in this game that literally make
you sound like a crazy person
foreign
a lot
foreign
nope
that will though
I don't know why I call the archery
avatars her
foreign
ER mask gotcha
okay that's actually kind of cool
I did not know that
guys where's the shack that you're
talking about I don't remember a shack
over here at all
foreign
that's the tower that I rode to
can I get into this Tower
without getting the um thingy
the gesture
wait
wait
yep tops is really important guys
oops tops
very important character in the game
I'm sure you get something better but
yeah
GG
I wonder if that activates anything down
here
what kind of like
doesn't it Queen America feel kind of
odd here
you know
I don't know overthink
it just drops a ladder right
I mean that's a lot cooler than what I
did to be honest
okay keep an eye out for a shack
there's a dungeon over there
right leernia
oh wow
who invades me here is this Edgar
must be right
yep the Revenger
hey man I didn't touch her
however I fed her eyeballs
I did feed her eyeballs sir
I don't know how you feel about that
okay not good not good not good
that's not fair that hurt a lot
your pulleys obscene
stop stop it stop with the helicopter
get out of here bro oh no
foreign
GG [ __ ]
damn you get a lot
we got another grape
did he kill all these people
foreign dumpling
I always call that attack the helicopter
every time
turn the camera on I said a hundred
members we're 25 away and I will start
using a camera again
promise
we've gotten like 50 new members today
it's 25 more you know what's 25 more
that's easy peasy
I think you just went on a rampage huh
the man is sad
do you guys think it's stupid that you
can't like your great room doesn't do
anything unless you have a rune Arc
enabled
got to GB
gonna fall
I wish they were like easier ways to get
Rune arcs I guess
you know what you should get Rune arcs
from is from the coliseums if you win
you get a rune Arc
like every duel every every match if you
win you get a rune Arc I don't know why
they didn't do that I feel like that's
such an easy like
thing to give but you just get nothing
for the coliseums
do I know the games went out for like
nine months now or like even longer and
we played the game for hundreds of hours
I still look at this game and go damn
this game's [ __ ] pretty
all the time I've already done it a few
times in this stream
thank you
no I don't know what moon swap is
you're locked away from gavel and Cannon
of Hyma because you killed
Bob
are those two spells
you know that's okay
we got our boy
well
look at you EG
we don't receive many visitors
I presume you are a tarnished
what brings you here
why does he just stop talking to you
right there oh pardon me
it's hardly my place to ask is it
I am EG
ypt a blacksmith once and an attack
Korean Royals
an old kojo who refuses we get what we
get
so here I am still quietly applying my
trade on this spot
perhaps you'd like a display
look at the sky box behind him here but
still able
beautiful bro
oh he doesn't have that
carrion Medallion we want
oh watch out there when I'm absorbed in
my smithing I lose sights of all else
if you come too close that's why it's
typical don't kill an NPC in seoul's
game unless needed I mean I got paid to
do it so that's okay
no
don't know what I work
I'm sure it's hard man
do we go into the carrion Manor folks
what time is it
I've been streaming for four hours what
the [ __ ]
it has not felt like it at all
let's try and get through here
I have not been keeping up oh
all right chat what other bosses have we
killed so far we've killed
let's see where we've been so
I don't think we we kind of left we're
we're in lorenia we killed the Glenstone
dragon
we killed
um Spear and staff
her stallion
we killed
balls
we killed the ERD tree Avatar here
I I gotta make sure I'm doing this yeah
it's not that big of a deal archery
Avatar lorenia
aurelians here
we killed Bloodhound dare will
which is back in Lim grave
which I think we already marked off yeah
we did
we kill electo
did we
oh wait we killed um box people
the times two demi-human chiefs yeah
yeah GB
I think we're caught up
we killed Edgar which is technically a
boss
okay cool
cool
all right let's get through the manor
I believe I marked the death bird
foreign
I don't think that was an option there
I didn't kill Alexa
you missed everything ghost
it's always the answer you missed
everything
all right let me go check I guess
let me just go [ __ ] take a look ski
doodle here
because that Talisman is really good
well then I presumed
[ __ ] Brave tarnished
a word of what this territory once
belonged to the Korean royal family
their Mana look at that Sky Box on this
point when the Raya Lucario Academy
turned on The Cardigans the Knights of
the cuckoo descended on this track
after leveling it
They carried on to the manor the
Guardians were taken off guard
but their strengths had not waned and
they repelled the knights onslaught
by Conjuring an enchanted snare that
remains potent to this day that is why I
say tarnished
Don't Go Near The Manor look at the
stars come out wish to lie with the
corpses of the heedless Knights of the
Goku
there it is life actually did that
TD quite a rare occurrence for such a
guarded Soul as he perhaps he sensed
something unusual about you at any rate
if you're friendly with Blythe I've
something else that might suit you
about advice no we already yeah yeah
there it is
lowers FP consumed by skills that's big
right
uh
big
okay
yo what's up T free how we doing man
agreed twisted
oh that's a hand
[Music]
wow
I didn't jump right
we want to talk to that guy up top right
because if we can get is that where I
get retaliation I think
that'd be big to have on like a shield
I might put the Rapier away
well that's I guess that's for various
specific attacks
oh ass hoe wait wait
I don't go there
I was gonna jump right there
do I jump there
no I can get there over here
oh come on
yeah I'm definitely not using the sword
of Knight and Flame
it's a big no-go for me chief
just chat how do I get to the dude who's
in the church
I think I think I messed up
I mean since I'm here I guess I'll just
grab it
oh it's really after Loretta really
yes
whoopsie
I thought it was before Loretta
see
sort of Saint Trina
that's some caled right
yeah I don't know if we like super want
carrion retaliation
but I'm gonna grab it in case we want it
later
for sure
is Perry hotter loves his parries
[Music]
foreign
I think it makes sense
I'm rock sling the hell out of this hole
though oh my God
well we want to kill Loretta anyway okay
foreign
nice
wow that is a weak sauce
gotta love Mike
stop it
bruh
[ __ ] no no
ow
that hurt
you kidding me
I'm gonna finish this
dude that came in so fast
she wants this distance man
oh I'm alive somehow bro I don't know
how but we're here
foreign
[Applause]
close one man
the red is great bow is pretty good
right
that was a close one bro
right GG
is Loretta's great bro pretty good
uses a sorcery yeah I'm definitely using
this
and then that
I don't know if Crystal release is good
but we need Terra magic as well heck
yeah bro
there we go we we just upgraded heavy
heavy upgrade just now
nah [ __ ] Pebble that's some weak [ __ ]
bro
let's go talk to Ronnie
wait [ __ ] I'm good
he went so far
foreign
excuse me
wow
I'm telling you sometimes like
fighting from a distance against certain
enemies is way harder than just being
like right next to them
avoid I'm gonna well I guess it doesn't
matter I'm just gonna make him disappear
yeah I'm just gonna stay close
and use the slicer
really
why does torrent not move what the [ __ ]
weren't just stood still for no reason
like I got on my horse and he just
didn't move he stood completely still
he's super resistant
this is annoying
what the [ __ ]
foreign
is just not doing anything I want him to
do
I think I have to use roxling
why is it being so annoying
it never moves this much
look look at this
are you
this Dragon literally never even moves
that much when I'm using just a giant
sword
what the heck is going on
what the [ __ ] is going on
foreign
thinks she flies away no matter what
yep
please
annoying Dragon bro annoying
waifu time waifu time
oh yeah we beat sakiro you can watch the
whole playthrough on the channel it's a
it's in its own playlist
so good it's such a good game
Mommy
all right chat
we're gonna talk to Mommy Ronnie
tomorrow
mommy Ronnie tomorrow I gotta take care
of the dogs
hey let's go GB
thanks for becoming in Eldon Lord bro
that's a big one that's a big sub or a
big membership man thank you
I appreciate it where we talked to
Ronnie tomorrow
guys
a bunch of memberships today I really
appreciate it if we get to uh
if we get to 100 members we can do you
know this at any point it didn't have to
be today by the way that we get to 100
members we're gonna do
um I'll start using a webcam again at
100 members and then uh
I will we're gonna do that cool
challenge run where whose idea was it I
don't remember whose idea was it it was
such a good idea in chat we spin a wheel
and whatever it lands on is what we
level up so it's like a
a wheel of level of Wheel of level or
whatever that's such a good idea so
we'll do that challenge run whenever we
get to 100 members and we're like 24
away from that so whenever we hit that
we'll start doing that run other than
that we're gonna pick this back up
tomorrow same you know our sorcery
wizard build
a lot of fun yeah it was red red potato
I think
yeah red potatoes
yeah the stat wheel run so we're really
close to that appreciate all the support
today a ton of members ton of super
chats ton of you know I just appreciate
y'all being here so
thank you very much
um we got to a hundred thousand Subs on
Christmas which was kind of a dream come
true for me so
I appreciate that guys thank you very
much for that too
um I'm probably gonna be streaming a lot
um for the rest of the year and then
into the new year as well we're gonna I
definitely want to stream a lot
alongside making just you know lore
videos whenever I can so
I'm having fun hope you're having fun
I'm out of here for today
and we'll be back tomorrow I didn't even
feel like I streamed for four and a half
hours it's crazy so
we'll be back tomorrow same time 10 a.m
CST and we'll pick it up again baby
you all have a great rest of your day
rest of your night
and we'll see you guys tomorrow thanks
again
peace out dudes bye bye bye bye